with Rising technology and the
exponential rise of websites on internet
there exist huge demands of SEO
professionals the salary of an SEO
professional at entry level can earn
between
$145,000 to1 90,000 per year by gaining
more experience you can unlock higher
salaries in this domain to gain
understanding of SEO here we bring you
SEO crash course that covers the
fundamentals of SEO we will start
understanding with what what is SEO and
why SEO is important moving ahead we
will see how search engine works and
what is on page and off-page SE we will
see how to carry out qw research in Su
how to build back links and take a
glimpse on technical SEO we will wrap up
this video by knowing how to get high
quality traffic to website how to rank
number one on Google some SEO tools and
how chat GPT can be used for so if you
are looking to become an Su professional
then look no further than simply learns
postgraduate program in digital
marketing gain in-depth knowledge of
search engine optimization with this
course you will also learn content
marketing web analytics keyword
management and research website
optimization and more unlock a whole
toolbox of skills including SE ranking
Hood suit Facebook Instagram LinkedIn
YouTube Twitter Google ads and Keyword
Planner don't miss out on this
opportunity to enroll in this course one
year of experience is preferred find the
course Link in description box for more
information hear the success stories
from our satisfied Learners in their own
words change is inevitable but growth is
optional for me both came hand in hand I
successfully changed my career from
software development to digital
marketing and simply learn presented the
perfect route hi I'm rad ra from Dubai
and I have completed the pgp in digital
marketing from Simply learn with puu
University when I shifted to Dubai from
Sri Lanka in
2015 I joined a group of company as a
software engineer but my interest in
content creation attracted me towards
the marketing industry intrigued by the
marketing functions I decided to take up
a challenge that would change my life
forever I aimed for a career change as
risky as it was the rewards were truly
overwhelming even though the journey
wasn't easy the pgp in digital marketing
with Fu University acted as not only a
catalyst but a game changer for my
career change with no professional
certification in marketing domain it was
difficult for me to transition and
change my career towards completely so I
decided to upskill with a professional
certification program I chose simply
learn because of its tremendously High
waiting to be r as one of of the best
Education portal online worldwide is
surely promising not only were the
ratings high but also the courses were
economically charge the modules were
very informative and amazing I still
refer to those while in the final stage
of my course I told my Superior about
the certification program I was doing
and then it offered me a digital
marketing role in the marketing
department as a digital marketing
executive yes that's how smooth it was
after working for a few years in the
same company as a digital marketing
executive I switch to a new role as a
digital marketing manager with this my
skill upgraded my salary increased and
my self-confident Boost alongside
numerous other positive outcomes I had a
chance to take a challenge and change my
career domain all together and I took it
so currently I'm pursuing masters of
Masters program from Simply learn where
I would complete eight master's program
including artificial intelligence cloud
computing and devops and many more
growing requires moving out of our
comfort zones keep learning so without
any further Ado let's get started with
what does SEO over to our tutors search
engine
optimization practice of getting traffic
organically through the search results
with the help of search engine is called
search engine
optimization Su increases the popularity
of your brand product or Services among
the audience
thereby increasing the chances of
conversion of lead to
customer traffic obtained organically is
more consistent once you are aware of
SEO strategies and start gaining
visibility in search results your site
will gain constant traffic that will
keep increasing with
time with SEO one can reach a large
audience to promote products and
services businesses can acquire
audiences from both the national and
international
levels SEO builds trust among the
audience for instance if your web page
is available on Google search results
the audience finds it worthy of trust
because of its online
presence your competitors are doing it
then you should also do it this could be
a serious note if your competitors are
doing this to rank high and gain
visibility you must also do it or remain
back in the
race let's understand it with the help
of an
analogy Susan started a business of
handmade toys she failed to gain enough
customers using traditional marketing
methods like newspaper advertisements
and Banners so she thought of putting
the business online thereby creating a
website the website was completely
optimized for search engines and was
soon visible on the search result
Pages the website started acquiring the
traffic which ultimately became her
customers the sales were boosted to an
unexpected level and the revenue has
increased
exponentially a good decision brought
huge success to Susan's business Susan
was thrilled with joy when a thought
struck across her mind
how are search engines able to find her
website so search engines can be Google
Bing yandu dug Duo Etc which work on
three basic
steps that are crawling indexing and
ranking first we will understand
crawling search engines are hungry for
content and so they send the Web spiders
also known as crawlers or Rewards or
search engine Bots to discover new
content or any updated content content
can be an image web page video or
anything else present on the web this
process is known as
crawling soon after the discovery of
content Web spiders start storing the
URL of the content into the search index
and this process is known as indexing
once the content is indexed it appears
in the search results for the relevant
searches when a user enters a search
query the most relevant search results
are taken from the index and displayed
from most relevant to least relevant on
the search result Pages this process is
known as ranking as title tags header
tags URLs alt text and
others list and describe onpage SEO
tactics that you should avoid describe
how natural language processing aims to
understand the meaning behind
text search engine optimization is very
very complex so when you're trying to
understand it for the first time I find
it's very easy and best to just break it
into general concepts that you already
have some understanding of so when I
look at the hundreds of con hundreds of
signals that go into SEO I break all of
them up into either relevancy and or
because sometimes it's both
popularity so relevancy popularity out
of all these signals they fit into one
of these two things throughout the rest
of this chapter in this course we're
going to break all the signals we have
into these two areas so that you can
rely on what you already know about the
concept of relevancy and the concept of
popularity to have some kind of Anchor
Point for these new brand these new
ideas in this section we're going to
talk about the on page factors and I'll
tell you right up front that these are
going to become your favorite these are
the ones that you have the most impact
on and that you can make a small tweak
and have a gigantic impact on the amount
of organic traffic that you send start
with one of my favorites title tags
title tags are the single most important
on page metric that we have access to
this is text that we get to express that
we get to write that shows the intent
and the purpose of that page on the
internet this is really really important
because search engines use this this
text that we get to provide in their
search results directly so we get to
write what becomes the headline of the
search result itself this uh in addition
to uh The Meta description as we'll
cover next are the two factors that we
have a whole lot of control over that
influence both click-through rates and
people's first impressions of our brand
next up we have metad descriptions now
met descriptions are a little bit
confusing because it is text that we get
to provide to search engines but more
often than not they override what we
provide and try to choose something that
is better in their opinion now I go both
ways with this sometimes it really is
better most of the time though in my
opinion it's not um but the important
thing here is that we get to provide
what would normally we'd have to pay for
with ad copy we get to provide it for
free customize it to however we want to
entice to entice clicks and the search
engines are happy to promote that and
show that in the search
results all right now we're getting to
the good nerdy stuff the header tags so
this was something that was built into
HTML when the web was first created uh
the idea here is that you're
establishing a hierarchy so you start
with one H1 uh saying what the main
purpose of the page is and you start to
break it into subcategories so you'll
have multiple H2S below that multiple
h3s between all of that now H1s used to
be a very important and primary SEO
metric that we got to use but because it
got abused it now has less of an
importance than it used to so it shows
what information is less or more
important than other information on the
page but it is no longer the strongest
indicator of what is the most important
page on that and right now that's still
title tags next up we have URLs uniform
resource locators now these are the
addresses of web documents online just
like you have a street address for your
house on the internet we have URLs for
any given document anywhere could be
PDFs it could be images it could be text
it could be your homepage all of these
have URLs these are extremely important
for SEO for a variety of reasons the
most important though is your keyword
usage you want to make sure that the
words that you're trying to rank for are
included in your URLs the second part of
this ties in directly the first is you
want to keep these short so it's not
okay to just put a whole lot of words
you want to rank for in url you need to
remember that humans are the people are
the things that use the internet they
share URLs they try to say them over the
phone they do all these different things
where it becomes extremely important to
keep these short and succinct so that
people can easily share them and can
type them in their browser with without
any issues now that we've talked about
the importance of URLs let's talk about
URL structure let's dive in a little bit
here we'll start with domain name so
you've probably heard of this concept
before in the example with the URL I
have here example.com would be the
domain name so this is the first thing
that people see with your online
business this is what's going to be in
all your advertisements it's going to be
in all your marketing efforts it's this
name right here I like to think of it in
terms of an offline world so if you're
walking around buildings typically look
like something so a barber shop almost
always looks like a barber shop a fast
food restaurant almost always looks like
a fast food restaurant that same idea is
going to apply to to domain names if you
have a very spammy looking domain name
or one that's hard to spell or one
that's confusing people are going to
make an initial impression off of that
so make sure that you have something
there that's going to make a great first
impression be something that's easy to
spell that one especially in this new
tech uh like Tech craziness that we live
in people do a terrible job of that but
something that's easy to spell and
something that's easy to pronounce and
easy to share
so how is this important to SEO well
keywords is are why it's important to
SEO this comes up all the time it's
important to have keywords in your
domain name as long as you're not taking
it too far now this is one of the things
I go back and forth with people all the
time how do you know if you've gone too
far uh I don't know I mean if it looks
like you bought the domain name simply
because it has the keywords in it that
you needed then you've probably gone too
far but is that the best way of
measuring it can I take out my
calculator and and actually calculate
that no you're just going to have to use
your gut you're going to have to look at
from a human from a human perspective so
do not go overboard keep it as short as
possible make sure it's something that
you can easily share something you're
going be able to put on your business
cards and be proud of not something that
you bought because you're doing it
purely for SEO reasons and you think
you're going to succeed okay so that is
the domain name now what about
everything after that so in this case it
would be this blog post that I wrote
well that is called subdirectories and
you can actually have um in theory
unlimited
subdirectories but from an SEO
perspective you do not want to do that
and it's for all the reasons we've
talked about before if you have lots of
directories it's going to be confusing
it's going to be hard to share uh it's
going to cause lots of problems in older
browsers so your best practice here is
to keep as few subdirectories as
possible this will be good for both
robots and for human beings with the
subdirectories as well as the files that
come after them you want to make sure
that you include your keyword so again
this is one of those weird things where
there's not a Quantified metric for it
but don't put the keywords in there too
many times but put them in there just as
as many times as you think is absolutely
necessary so generally this says once or
maybe twice if it's already in the
domain name
okay that's all the information I have
right now on URLs feel free to uh Google
this subject if you if you want to know
more about it because trust me there's a
whole lot of technical knowledge that
goes into this but if you're at this
point you already understand all the
most important parts of it as you likely
realize computers cannot see images the
same way that humans can uh they do not
have eyes and they do not have the
complex brains that we use to get
meaning out of pictures out of pixels so
because of that we've had to come up
with some other way of expressing the
meaning behind images luckily the
creators of the internet were Forward
Thinking and they provided us with a
factor called image alt text alt text is
the alternative text that is shown when
image can't load this is done on purpose
so that people who are blind are able to
extract meaning from something when they
can't see it this worked out really well
for search engines because well they're
effectively effectively blind and so
that they can also use that information
put into the image alt text to
understand the meaning behind
images internal links so we have an
entire section on links but what I want
to cover at this point is just internal
links an internal link is a link that
points from your website back to a
different section of your own website it
is not pointing elsewhere it's not
coming from elsewhere is from your
website back to your own website this is
important from a relevance a relevancy
perspective you'll see internal links in
your main navigation when you'll have
one that likely says home one that might
say contact us or one that says about
what you're showing to search engines
and to humans is that this section that
if you click on this link will be about
our company or this will be a place
where you can find contact information
for us these links are not votes like
external links but they are relevancy
metrics that are extremely
helpful when a search engine crawls and
processes your website it doesn't simply
look for the instances of keywords it's
a lot more complex than that it's using
a technology called NLP natural language
processing what is trying to do is it's
using algorithms to try to understand
the meaning of text the same way humans
do when they listen to other people talk
or read read text instead of just
looking for specific phrases or like the
order of words it tries to extract
what's behind IND that what is what is
trying to be expressed here emotion
feeling food anything so when a search
engine goes to your website it may seek
keywords but it was looking for context
to that you may say just soccer but just
having the word soccer on your website
isn't going to help you rank
specifically for soccer what you need to
do and what is more common and actually
happens naturally is that you'll happen
to use words like goal and World Cup and
referee Google and the other search ches
are going to take these into account and
understand what that you rank for soccer
or that you're relevant for that kind of
keyword by the usage of other synonyms
and other common words that are used
within the context of a bigger broader
idea the next on-site signal that we
have is site Maps now there's two kinds
of site Maps there's the kind that are
for humans and there's the kinds that
are for robots or crawlers or spiders
the ones that are for humans are called
HTML sitemaps and you've probably seen
these before they're generally in the
footer of a website click through it and
it shows you the major sections of a
website and usually provide some search
functionality those help you understand
as a human what the hierarchy of a
website is how how does everything fit
together and how do I get to the to
something I'm looking for as quickly as
possible those are called HTML site maps
and like I said they're generally for
humans there's also something that
exists on the back end called an XML
sitemap now this is something you can
actually look at but it's formatted for
computers so it's not going to be easy
to read an XML sitemap uses a format
called XML as you can probably imagine
to show the hierarchy and the priority
of each of the URLs on your website uh
so that search engines can understand
that and figure out how everything is
interconnected so at this point we've
covered a lot of things that are
important and things that you should be
doing and optimizing now let's go the
different direction and cover the things
that you should not be doing so these
are the list of the most common mistakes
that I see uh that should not be done
for a well optimized page the first one
is keyword stuffing so back in the day
it used to be helpful and again this is
in the past it's not true anymore it
used to be helpful to put lots of
instances of the keyword that you were
trying to rank for on the page search
engines and humans for that matter are a
lot smarter about this now than they
used to be keyword stuffing does not
work you're not going to rank better for
uh any given phrase by including it 100
P 100 times on the page so this is
something that doesn't work you should
not do it anymore next one is hidden
text unfortunately I still see this one
all over the web this is when you write
content that is solely for search engin
it's not for people uh and you'll put it
say white text on a white background so
a search engine can see this because
they're crawler they're a machine uh but
humans cannot because they cannot see
the difference because there's no
contrast now that also used to work back
in the day but it does not and is not a
useful thing to invest your time in
today uh search enges can tell when it's
white text on a white background that's
actually very easy to tell from a from a
computer science point of view it's uh
there's other ways of trying to hide
things but when you hi text modern
search engines are most certainly smart
enough to be able to figure that out
probably better than humans to be to be
honest so don't bother trying to hide
text just for search Eng they're going
to figure it out and it's going to work
against
you next one is repetitive anchor text
so we've all read these articles where
you get to a page and it just doesn't
feel like it was written for people
you're reading a sentence and it's
redundant it's got lots of links in it
that really don't need to be links it's
it confuses the way the flow of of the
information on the page because you put
links when they're really they're not
necessary this also used to be a tactic
that used to work but is no longer
helpful search engines the uh natural
language processing algorithms they used
have advanced significantly so they can
tell when something is not readable when
something is probably intended for
maches and not for people so do not
waste your time on redundant links and
trying to trying to sculpt your page
rank or your your link Equity or the
value of your links anyway like that
because just today's world it does not
work the last thing that we have on here
is cloaking cloaking is the idea of
showing one thing to search engines and
something entirely different to humans
now this is also like everything else on
this something that used to work but as
I've mentioned before search engines
have their algorithms have gotten much
smarter and much more clever and they
can almost always figure out the
difference between when you're doing
this if you're showing one thing to
search enges and something else to
humans with a with only a few exceptions
that I know of which are in the process
of going out there's no reason to do
this so it is not something worth
investing your time
in now we've covered all the most
important onpage optimization factors
let's take a look at what the
theoretical perfectly optimized page
would look like on the internet now
there's a big asteris here in that well
no page would be perfectly optimized
because the internet's Dynamic and fluid
and things change all the time but if
there was one it would look very eer
eerily similar to what we're about to
talk about let's start with the basics
you need to have a title tag the title
tag needs to have optimized keywords in
it preferably closer to the beginning of
it and it needs to be clear and enticing
for users to click remember this is what
we're going to actually see in search
results for most of the time for your
search for for the search result itself
is you're going to have this text here
so a clear and optimized tile tag the
next thing is an enticing metad
description now remember metad
descriptions are not used for ranking
purposes but they are tremendously
important important for click-throughs
uh so this is the this is your chance to
write copy that's going to entice people
to click through your result rather than
the other ones that are going to be on
the search result page after that we
have a short optimized URL so the
important here thing here is that it
needs to be short so it's easily
sharable so it's easy to understand from
a search engine perspective but it also
needs to contain the keywords that
you're trying to rank for so keep it
there keep it in plain ink English use
the phrases people are actually using to
get to your site uh but keep it as
concise as humanly possible now let's
talk about the page itself uh what does
this actually look like how are things
structured well the first thing you want
to do is you're going to want to make
sure that it is structured in the same
way that people expect to see websites
meaning there is a title at the Top If
it's appropriate there's some kind of
navigational elements around the site uh
there are pictures to make this um
worthy of me to spend the five minutes
of my internet time uh grazing looking
at your content and you need to have
text that is well written and this all
is very hard to quantify but it's things
that you're going need to just just take
a look at and and work with your team
for things that are interesting there's
an attitude with the page that has some
kind of opinion it's expressing
information it's giving me the answers
to whatever question I may have I need
to make sure this content at the end of
the day is written for humans that's
something that I would share with my
best friend because I think this is the
single best source on the Internet for
whatever my information need is at that
moment after that it needs to be bot
accessible so I actually see this
problem all the time uh with some of the
major news Publications the world
they'll have a really outstanding
article they'll have a really beautiful
uh photo gallery but they've done it in
a way where the search engines can't see
it which means that on the Internet it's
almost useless which is which is a shame
it's sad when this happens what you need
to do is you need to make sure that you
have the world's best content which is
hard enough but you also have to make it
accessible to search engine so this is
certainly very doable just avoid
Technologies like flash and say silver
light and use more of these Open
Standards like HTML 5 that'll get you
all the way there the next one is social
it needs to be social it needs to be
shared sharable so I had mentioned the
my um when I'm trying to create content
that the bar that I tried to rise to is
that is sharable for my best friend well
you need to facilitate that sharing you
need to have some kind of way for them
to actually share it so this could be as
simple as adding uh the social sharing
buttons or it could be something as easy
as enticing them and giving them a call
to action at the end of the article to
share it with their friends or share it
with people who are important to them uh
sharing on the Internet is extremely
important not just for ethical reasons
but for marketing reasons for bottom
line reasons uh so make sure that you're
facilitating that the last one and is
certainly not the least important one uh
is Multi-Device ready so I don't care if
you use adaptive design I don't care if
you use responsive design just make sure
that this content that you spent so much
time crafting is going to work and is
going to be consumable easily on my
tablet and on my phone and on my
gigantic TV and all these other devices
so that when it comes time when you
finally earned that person coming to
your website to consume your really
wonderful content that they're able to
see it on whatever device it may be
holding so this is a general overview of
what a perfectly optimized website would
look like now remember this this is
going to shift depending on context but
make sure if you cover to cover all of
these bases so that the signals that
we've all talked about make sense and
you have a real lasting impact with this
keywords are the ideas or topics that
clearly describe what your content is
about say for example here the title of
the slide is what is keyword aearch
so this is the keyword which suggests
that this slide contains the content
about keyword
research so basically keyword research
is a process of identifying keywords or
popular Search terms that people tends
to search for when you identify relevant
keywords all you need to do is include
these keywords smartly into your cont
content and this will help your content
to get higher rankings and search
results now the question arises why does
keyword research has so much of
importance in search engine
optimization let's understand this
keyword research plays a major role in
driving traffic organically to your
website or your content but how does
this exactly happens when you select the
most approp roate keyword for your
content there is an
opportunity where you can rank high in
search results by ranking higher there
are more chances that audience can
discover your content and reach to your
website thus you get more and more
consistent traffic growth for your
website thereby indirectly promoting
your products and services now that you
are aware of how keyword research holds
importance let's now see some essential
types of keywords that is longtail
keywords and short tail keywords so
first we will start with longtail
keywords longtail keywords are the
keywords that are mostly used to get
more specific results longtail keywords
include keywords with three or more
words
for example shoes for a black dress now
coming to short tail keywords short tail
keywords are the general keywords or
most specifically General Search terms
short tail keywords include one or two
words in the keyword for example
shoes now let's see the difference
between both the longtail and short tail
keywords by demonstrating let's go to
google.com so now we are here to check
the difference between long tail
keywords and short tail keywords so
first we will check for the short tail
keyword now suppose I am looking for the
shoes that should go perfectly with my
beautiful black dress so here I add
shoes and see how the results are
appearing okay if you see the
recommendations here we get shoes for
men shoes for women shoes images Sho
size chart shoes for rainy season etc
etc and if I enter here only shoes what
are the results here I get number of
results from the shopping
websites
uh with the very number of
shoes with number of Brands and
somewhere locations of the SHO
shops but none of the result is
relevant to what I am expecting that is
the shoes for my black dress okay so
now I'll just
change my search query I'll add a long
tail keyword
here and I will search here more
specifically for what I
wanted so here I'll add shoes
for
black dress
okay so here I am getting number of
ideas the image ideas in the search
result that what kind of shoes are going
to go best with my black dress and here
I'm getting several combinations which I
can wear with my black dress so 12 best
color shoes here again I'm getting If
You observe clearly then all these
results are completely aligned to what
exactly I am looking for
okay and if I again change this
query more specific like shoes for black
dress for
woman let's see what I get so here I'm
getting more specific
results in terms of
women's we will definitely understand
how to use longtail keywords or short
tail keywords during our research in the
upcoming part of this video Let's now
have a look on tools required for
carrying out keyword
research here I have got a small list of
tools that you will need to perform
effective keyword research so first we
will begin with Keyword
Planner Keyword Planner is a free
keyword research tool provided by Google
some of the important features of
Keyword Planner includes discovery of
new keywords estimate monthly searches
for a
keyword get the average cost of ads for
the keyword you're looking for and help
to organize keywords the next tool that
we have in our bucket is sem
Rush some important features of sem Rush
includes helps to get competitor
keywords data it helps to get competitor
backlinks data finds competitors top
performing content helps in getting
competitors campaign data Etc let me
bring it to your notice that sem Rush is
one of the best platforms that fulfill
all your SEO needs so do visit to
semrush.com you can find the link in the
description box below next tool that we
have in our bucket is RS the free
keyword generator tool by RS helps to
discover keyword ideas helps in
identifying the search volume
estimations identify easy keywords for
which you can possibly rank for helps
you to get a list of of longtail
keywords and however it is not limited
to Google searches only Yes you heard it
right you can get keyword ideas for
Google Bing
YouTube Yahoo Etc now let's check
another tool which is Google
Trends Google Trend will come into
action during your keyword research when
you're looking for the top search
queries by users that is the most
trending query moreover you can check
these details of search queries for your
country for any other country or even
worldwide not only this but you can also
choose a type of search for this query
like web search emage search YouTube
search Etc the next tool that we have is
answer the public tool answer the public
tool tool has free as well as paid
versions this tool can prove a magic
wand for your business as it suggests
the questions that are asked by people
in your industry this can help you to
understand and create strategies for the
content that the users are searching
across the internet and the last tool in
our today's list is keywordtool.io
keyword tool to. I has free as well as
paid versions keyword tool. I helps to
get keyword ideas from various sources
like Google YouTube Bing Amazon eBay
Instagram Twitter Pinterest Etc we will
definitely understand how to use these
tools in the upcoming part of the video
to make use of these tools it is
necessary to understand how to perform a
keyword research in the section on
onpage optimization we talked about
factors that's centered on relevancy in
this section we're going to go in a
different direction and we're going to
talk about the signals that focus on
popularity so what does popularity mean
in this context well it's actually quite
simple popularity always relates to
links to hyperlinks on the web so you
have seen these when you see the
typically blue text that is underlined
what this is is a um tool it's a ah ref
technically in HT tml that is pointing
from one web document to a different one
uh this is a pretty simple concept I
imagine you already know this so what
does this mean from an SEO perspective
well it turns out that this gigantic
group of signals the ones related to
hyperlinks are and are and historically
have been the line share of signals that
the search engines process when trying
to rank Pages now there's one big
problem with these from an SEO
perspective um is that they are
historically and today very difficult to
influence uh this is because they do not
take place on your website they take
place elsewhere it's other people who
are linking to you generally speaking
and this makes them very very difficult
to have an influence on so this is a
good thing and a bad thing it's a good
thing because it it turns out to be a
great metric for ranking web documents
it's a bad thing because it's hard for
us to make an impact on day-to-day level
hands down the most time-consuming and
difficult part of SEO is link building
now there's a lot of reasons for this um
primarily because it's constantly
changing and because of all the elements
that are involved with this but the big
the bigger takeaway here is that there's
no one siiz fits-all solution for link
building you have to take the context of
your business or of your website and you
have to apply general principles to that
so in this video we're going to cover
these general principles so you can
figure out how to apply those to your
business these principles are and I
think these are the most clever and the
most important ones are creating link
worthy content proactively participating
in off-site engagement and utilizing
offline relationships the tried andrue
method for building links is creating
content that's optimized for humans so
let me explain what this means the
currency of the internet if you will is
the content itself that's why people go
on they want to read the newest article
or they want to see the newest video
whatever it may be that is what has been
true since the beginning and I have no
doubt will be true going forward so as
an SEO or as an online marketer in
general you can use this to your
advantage creating the content that
people are going to want to share with
their friends or they're going to want a
site in any kind of paper or whatever
they're working on that is a tried
andrue way of getting links this is what
we call the power of content you can do
all kinds of bells and whistles you can
go do these newest tactics you can try
all these different things out but at
the end of the day what's really
important is the content itself so this
is what I focus on this is where 80% of
my time goes on when I'm working on link
building it's on the content itself can
I create something that is just truly
that is so truly great that someone
essentially has to link to it this is
what I focus on trying to answer and
while there is no simple answer to that
going asking that question always sets
you in the right direction the next
strategy that I want to talk about is
actually very counterintuitive so if
you're trying to build links to your own
website I found one of the most
effective ways and this is consistently
true is to engage off your own site H
now this doesn't make any sense right
why would you work on other people's
websites if you're trying to promote
your yourself well think about human
beings human beings are much more likely
to link and give back to people to human
beings that they know well so a lot of
the time I spend when I'm doing link
building is spend offsite engaging with
others so sometimes this is through
social media so I'll use whatever the
latest social network is and I'll chat
with people there who have similar
interests or have similar interests to
what I'm trying to promote be it a
different topic or be it a new industry
all altogether I'll spend a lot of time
promoting others and a lot of times
chatting with other people building up
genuine real relationships with human
beings so that when comes time for them
to write an article or when it's when
they're ready to link out to other
people I'm the first person they think
to and they link back to my website one
of the reasons that link building is so
hard is because the internet moves so
fast what worked yesterday might not
work tomorrow so one of the most clever
and easy ways to avoid this problem is
to just simply go offline utilize some
of the relationships that you have off
of the internet in order to benefit on
the internet this is something I try to
do all the time because it consistently
works by far the easiest favors to cash
in on are the ones that you already owed
so these might be from your friends who
you work with these might be from
friends who from childhood these are
people who you actually know in the real
world who are much more likely to help
you when you're trying to promote new
content online so when I'm trying to do
link building one of the things I focus
on is people that I know in the real
world
so this can be lots of things this can
be personal friends who happen to have
websites and blogs this can be friendly
competition you have or friendly allies
you have in your space just saying hey
we're looking for these kind of things
can you help us out and we maybe I'll
help you out somewhere else it's
utilizing these relationships that Exist
Elsewhere so that you can start gaining
these links yourself uh if that doesn't
work if maybe you don't have any friends
in these Arenas you can always go to
local businesses and uh local agencies
so sometimes this is um like government
owned things sometimes this is just
third parties all together there's lots
of things that they need help with that
you as a business owner or you as uh
trying to promote some client may be
able to help them with and if you can
help them offline they're more much more
likely to help you online when link
building it's very important to
understand that not all links are are
created equally a link coming from the
homepage of CNN is going to provide a
lot of what we call link Equity it's
going to have a lot of popularity
metrics tied to it and so it's going to
be more valuable to you and help you
rank higher whereas a link also coming
from the homepage but let's say Joe Mo's
spam blog that is not going to be
particular helpful for you and it
actually in some cases could hurt you so
when you're going out and doing link
building make sure that you can stand
behind the source of the link that is
coming at you this could be in a good
example from like a government website
where it's trusted in a bad example this
could be from a website that you would
not normally go to even on your own in
addition to that there's different kinds
of links depending on the direction that
they're going so if a link is coming
towards you towards your website that's
called an inbound link these are the
ones that are very helpful for
popularity metrics that we've talked
about there's also outbound links these
are links that you linking to other
people now generally there's a big
misconception about this that you would
think you would not want to link out to
other people but if you just follow the
natural chain of events and you look at
people who are writing blogs without SEO
in mind you'll see that they are linking
out naturally and it's these natural
patterns that the search engines are
looking for so there's absolutely no
problem in linking out just as long as
it's to sources that you actually do
trust so there's inbound links there's
outbound links there's links that have a
lot of popularity value so like from a
established Government website or from
something popular like CNN there's also
links that are inbound that are not
going to have as much value for you that
you probably don't want to spend your
time building now regardless of where
your links are coming from it's
important to look out for one particular
attribute it's called real no follow
real no follow was a tool that was
originally developed to combat comment
spam like on blogs you'd have lots of
people who were leaving um completely
irrelevant comments so that they could
link back to their own website and get
credit for that way that does not work
at all today uh one of the primary
reasons for that is the search
introduced something called real no
follow where they said here's a link
that's going out from my website but I
do not stand behind it and it does not
pass any credit a lot of times when
you're doing link building you'll get a
link which you're very proud of coming
from somewhere very popular but then
realize that it has this attribute
attached to it no follow uh and which
means you will not get any credit for it
so make sure that when you're doing your
link building that the link coming at
you that you've earned does not have
this attribute associated with it
otherwise you will get no credit for it
now that you understand what no follow
is let's let's talk about the biggest
use case for this social media most of
the links that we see in social media
are valueless uh this is because they're
either uh hidden from search engines
entirely this mostly happens on Facebook
or they're visible to search engines but
they use this Ro this ra no follow
attribute which means that they're
useless so while social media does have
many many benefits uh SEO and
particularly link value from SEO is not
one of the direct benefits of
participating in social media now that
we've covered some of the link building
dues let's talk about some of the link
building don'ts so these are things that
you should not do uh because you'll be
wasting your time and possibly more
importantly your money the first one is
Spam so we have all seen this online
when you go somewhere and you see just a
bunch of spammy links links that are
clearly written only for uh machines
only for search engines a lot of times
these will have the name of
pharmaceutical drugs on them a lot of
times they'll have um just be completely
irrelevant to the content while these
have worked in some instances they are
certainly not a best practice and they
are certainly not a long-term strategy
so I never recommend trying to invest in
spammy links this way because it's not
going to ultimately help you in fact in
many ways it'll probably hurt you so do
not go out of your way to try to get
spammy links the next one is buying
links this is these are to closely tied
together now buying links is when you go
out and try to buy sometimes relevant
sometimes irrelevant links and again
this is something that had worked
sometimes historically not always my
biggest problem with this is not so much
the ethical problem although there is
one there uh search Eng have clearly
said not to ever do this um my biggest
problem with it is that you canot
calculate an accurate Roi on this so if
you spend a dollar on this you don't
know if you're going to make a dollar or
$2 doar back you have no idea there's no
way to accurately measure this so you
have no idea if this if this is valuable
to you or not where as opposed to if
you're creating valuable content you can
measure that and you can directly tie it
to Sales so your your money dollar for
dooll spent much much more effectively
on content than it is on buying links so
I highly recommend do not spend spend
your time or your money buying links the
last one is acquiring reciprocal links
so reciprocal links as you can imagine
are links that go in a circle you link
to somebody and they link directly back
to you now in the natural web when no
marketing is taken place into this
there's no kind of manipulation trying
to go on that happens that happens all
the time so don't go out of your way and
be afraid of this happening so one news
site will very regularly link to another
news article and that article might link
back to them somewhere else that happens
so don't stress about this too much but
don't go out of your way to try to build
all of your links and reciproc way we're
overthinking this by trying to link to
somebody else who links to a third party
that third party links to you don't
waste your time this is just not a
factor that you should worry about
reciprocal links are not generally as
good as oneway links but it happens so
often that is not is not worthy of your
time or any kind of investment trying to
avoid
this the concept of linking is
foundational to good rankings and
understanding the internet at large it
starts with the premise that good
content will be C Ed by others
recommending it to other people how we
site and recommend information online is
by linking to it we link to information
that we find
valuable based on that the search
engines assess content by how websites
link to one another so we are going to
cover the definition and purpose of
links and the different functions that
links serve we'll also look at how links
mirror human
judgment we'll look at how search
engines evaluate links by mirroring
human judgment and how that affects
what's called Block Level
analysis and how where the location of
different links and how they are used
will greatly affect their
relevance we're going to look at how
visitors from different link sources
will behave differently based on where
they came from and also how you can
measure the effectiveness of links and
finally we're going to look at both good
and bad linking practices now links
serve a number of
purposes from a functional standpoint
they usually are our primary means of
navigation online we click on links we
go to different pages and from those
pages we find links to other Pages links
are also a method of citing other
content when we quote somebody when we
use information that we have found
somewhere else we site that information
to give credit to the original author
typically online we do that with a link
so that if someone wants to see the
original Source document it's available
to them that also helps to provide
credibility to you credibility to the
author of the original source as well as
assigning importance to the knowledge
that came from that original source and
the authority of the original source
links also provide us with a clear
structure of how our websites are built
how the pages relate to one another and
how organized the information can
be so let's break down the functional
part of a link this is important if
you're going to be developing anchor
text and linking to understand the
structure the
ahre equals is the start of the link tag
what you are doing is developing the
reference of where the document is
contained that's the hre reference is
what it is short
for what comes next within the quotes is
the location of the document now this
can be a full URL or you may just be
linking to a document that's on the main
root level of your
server this is the full location where
you can access the document and so
you're putting the name of the document
the extension so that it will be
linked the next part is what I have in
caps you'll notice off to the left I
have something in all blue text and
underlined which most people will
recognize as a link you see when it is
in between the document location and the
closing of the link tag the text you
have in there is what's called anchor
text you see instead in of publishing
the document location and the full URL
of the document we can put the link
within text and create anchor text so
all someone has to do is click on the
link and the document loads for them
this anchor text is vitally important to
understanding how we can add additional
relevance to linking
content then we see the closure of the
link tag this this is what makes the
internet the internet is millions of
pages connected together by
Links so when we look at the functional
side of links and we look at this
example here as you can see the title of
this article is not the URL address of
the article it's a title and the title
is the link that is the anchor text of
the link and so from a search engine
standpoint search engines look to see
what words are being used in the link
and how relevant those words are to the
document that is being
linked it also looks to see where is the
link is it in the editorial information
in the article is it part of the
navigation is it in a sidebar or is it
an
ad and then also search engines are
looking to see if this is a text link or
or an image
link how long has that link been there
what type of link is it does it go
somewhere within your website does it go
to another website or is it a reciprocal
link which I will explain more later
they also look to see the text in the
link and the context of the page with
the link directs you
to we utilize links a little differently
you see from a human standpoint
whenever we refer information to another
person when we provide reference
material to another person or even if
someone asks us for a recommendation we
provide this information you see offline
we mirror the same behavior as we do
online when we link people ask us for
information and we provide it we just
mirror that online by making a link
offline we recommend we refer we provide
information to each other in much the
same way the way I want you to think
about it from a human standpoint is that
if you asked another person for advice
or directions or a referral are there
certain people that you would trust more
than
others I'm sure the answer to that is
yes and maybe you have some people in
mind that you are thinking about you see
we run across the same issue with search
the the search engines know that there
are some websites that are much more
trustworthy than
others just like if you were to ask
someone for information I'm sure you
would ask the right person for the
information you would ask the most
knowledgeable trustworthy person you
knew who had Authority in that subject
area the search engines are trying to do
the same thing with the links that we
publish on our websites they're trying
to determine who is the most trustworthy
and relevant based on the
recommendations referrals and citations
of other websites to other websites who
are the websites that are trusted that
are authorities the search engines are
trying to do from a technical
algorithmic standpoint what we do
naturally from a human
standpoint now from The Human Side as I
had said before we need to think of
links as
information that we receive from other
people Word of Mouth advice information
directions
recommendations this is where we need to
think about links not from the
standpoint of building false relevance
for a search engine but being a helpful
resource for our readers how can we help
them how can we provide information and
how can we be a credible source of
information how can we develop our
Authority within the industry and so
that people who have questions about
this content will see our websites as
authoritative and credible
resources the best way to develop links
as you'll see is good content when
people like what they read when they
like what they see when they are willing
to recommend it to others it it's
because you have created something of
value and they'll link to you when they
feel that you are credible and that you
are authoritative with this information
only then will they share it with other
people because you have earned that
right for them to share it with others
by providing content that is informative
educational entertaining and you've
provided that service only then will
people then want to recommend it to
others by by linking to
it now links serve a number of benefits
When I look at some of the incoming
links to my site one of the things I
notice is that if I get a link in
certain places that can drive a lot of
brand exposure I can have thousands of
people coming to the site looking to see
an article and that provides a lot of
exposure to a lot of
people however also getting a link from
a certain website
especially if it's a high relevant
authoritative website I can see my
rankings increase because of
that but then also a good link is going
to drive people that will convert and
drive sales or leads those who become
customers so those are the three aspects
of a good link a good link will drive
traffic to your site a good link will
assist your rankings and a good link
will bring in business if you can get a
link to do all three of those at the
same time that's what I call the golden
link because it has all three
benefits usually however you're going to
find that different links will provide
different types of benefits one of these
three or maybe two out of these three
one of the things I'm usually very
focused on is the link that drives sales
or generates leads that's getting links
in the right place that will benefit me
tangibly rather than just getting
thousands of people to see
it why it benefits me financially if I
can get a link in the right
place so from here let's break down the
different types of links we have
navigational links we see these in our
navigation our primary navigation maybe
the footer of our web pages where we
have links to typical information such
as about us or contact us we also have
sidebar links this might be related
information or offers or calls to
action and then also I would break it
down into outbound or inbound type of
navigation outbound are links going to
other websites inbound links are links
that come from other websites and that
also I might send to other pages on my
own
site now I've used the term editorial an
editorial link is a link that is found
within the content of the website and by
that I mean through an article so if I
am writing an article and I link to
someone else and cite them or reference
them that is what's called an editorial
link it means that it's part of the
content a great example of this is that
the navigation on your web pages is not
part of the content it serves a function
function as
navigation but it doesn't have anything
to do with supporting information with
citing an authority so information and
links that you put within the content
and presented content of your site are
considered
editorial now there's also call to
action links where you're bringing
someone to a landing page or a
registration page or a sale
page then also we have Social Links now
these can provide a a variety of means
but typically a social link will go to a
profile maybe it's a username that takes
you somewhere else or a comment or maybe
just an image or something that goes to
a social site or that you have placed on
your own site as
well either way it's all contained
within that social network even though
the links are going on and off your site
they tend to be controlled in that
social environment
now I've used the term reciprocal link
now this
is something very specific a reciprocal
link is one where you would go to
somebody else and you would make a trade
such as if you link to me I'll link to
you and maybe you put those links on the
homepage or maybe you create a page just
for that link you see sometimes it just
doesn't make sense and so the search
engines will see that you've linked to
each other but if there's no contextual
relevance if there's no contextual
relevance most likely you won't get any
benefit because you've agreed to link to
each other for the primary purpose of
boosting rankings now this is not to say
that two websites can't link to each
other because there is some relevance
we'll look at some examples of that
later on in this
module also then we have advertising
links
these can be ads banners anything on the
page that is an advertising link that if
you were to click on it you would go to
that advertisers page those links are
typically through an ad server and they
take place in entirely different
ecosystem but they are links and we need
to know what kind of links are
advertising and which kind of links are
functional to our
websites now when I broke down the
different types of links
so we have our navigation links we have
links in our sidebar and in our footer
what Block Level analysis does is that
the search engines look at the code of
the page they break down the page
because it's very easy to figure out
which part of the code has to do with
your navigation which part of the code
has to do with your sidebar and your
footer and which part of the code is
calling ads from an ad server what this
leaves is the editorial content your
article and the ability of search
engines then to break down your page
into these different elements the reason
why they do it is that the links
contained in the editorial space are
considered to be more relevant in terms
of linking to other websites than any of
the other types of links on your web
page search engines don't consider all
parts of the page to be equally relevant
which is okay because neither do humans
we look at the navigation as utilization
pure utility because it's just helping
me navigate among the different pages of
your website I'm not expecting to learn
anything I'm using it as a functional
means of navigating your site now your
sidebar might have some calls to action
it might have links to other pages but
it's not an article it's what you've
developed and so it might be a little
more important than your navigation but
it's not as important as what you may
have written within content your footer
navigation is basically the same you
control that it's the same on every page
and so what the search engines are
looking for are the unique content the
unique article or information that
you've published and if there is a link
within that editorial content that is
highly relevant because it has to do
with content it has to do with
information that you are sharing and so
the links there are going to be more
highly relevant and are going to be more
important for the search engines to see
you see it's the same way with humans
we're not going to look at navigation to
learn something it's functional the same
thing with the footer and as humans
we're reading the content that you have
in your article and if you link to
another source well you've provided us
with utility but it's contextual utility
because you're citing where you found
information or you're citing an
additional Source or you are linking to
an example and it enables me as a human
to see that
understand it and if I need that
additional information I can click on it
and go to it so I'm going to look at the
information on the page in that article
very differently than I'm going to look
at the headings the navigation the
sidebars or the footer because the
article is what is informing me and so
the links in the article I'm going to
look at very differently and hold them
in a higher level of
relevance now over time search engines
have had to refine the algorithm about
links you see in the early days of
search engine algorithms they used to
Simply count the amount of links then if
one site had more links than another
that made it more credible however once
people started to figure that out people
started accumulating links by really any
means necessary and they were just
looking for the sheer volume of links
because they knew if they got the most
amount of links it would affect their
rankings and so over the years the
search engines have had to change and
adjust and add more relevance to their
algorithm refine it in order to look at
different aspects of links in order to
properly determine relevance so over
time it wasn't just having a link it was
then also looking at how many people
site this site as an authority so
looking at the source of the link and
the types of pages then also looking at
the text of the link and matching it
with the text of the page does it match
is it
contextual and then looking at the type
of Link doing the Block Level
analysis and then also the context the
relevancy of your site compared to the
linking site compared to the link and
the information that's being shared
there also some of the ways that they
can look at it are the age of the link
how long has that link been there humans
do the same thing when we look to see
how long someone has been in business
we're looking at
credibility and then of course there are
many many other ongoing refinements that
are going into the search engines
evaluations of links sometimes the age
of the link isn't as relevant especially
when you're looking for something that
has happened very recently an Old Link
could mean that it's old news or that
something has changed since then so
search engines are in a con Stant battle
to ensure that people are not gaming the
system by falsely creating relevance
through
linking the link relevancy and the
algorithm is all about trying to
determine who is the most relevant and
credible within this area and that is
the focus of most search engine
algorithm refinements over the past few
years and it will be into the future now
this is is where I'm going to start
bringing in some screenshots from a link
Management
program as a search engine Optimizer a
link Management program is probably
going to be one of your best friends as
you move along in this
industry in this example this program
linkex that I'm using will track the
incoming links to my website and it'll
also provide a breakdown as to what type
of website those links are coming from
so I can see how many links I have from
blogs how many links I have from news
sites how many links from wikis how many
links from directories forums social
media public relations sites articles or
additional
resources then I can also add my
competitors and I can compare where I
stand in terms of the amount of links
from each source and where my
competitors stand in this way I can be
sure that we all have a similar link
profile you see if my linking profile
looks vastly different than all my
competitors the search engines are going
to see that as well and know that
something might be different with me
good or bad and that's going to raise a
red flag so I want to look at the
linking profile because every industry
and almost every business's linking
profile is going to be a little
different but especially among
Industries we see that linking profiles
that is the amount of links from
different sources it's going to be
slightly different for every different
type of industry or business so this
helps me understand where my links are
coming from which is vitally important
because from a business standpoint one
thing that I've tracked consistently in
analytics is that people will act
differently and also I can predict which
source is going to send me the best
customers you see just because someone
comes from a link doesn't mean they're
going to buy or become a customer or
really become a lead many times they're
going to come look at your information
and leave and based on how they come to
your site whether it's through a Blog a
directory a forum or a new site has a
lot to do with how they view your
website and it's all about the
context you see this is what I've
learned over the years is that people
will behave differently based on how
they find the website what I found is
that people from blogs news sites and
articles they tend to stay longer do
more and have a higher chance of
conversion of becoming a customer or a
lead the main reason is because blogs
and articles they have a lot of context
it's an article someone has taken the
time to write some information out and
then link to my site which means there
is a highly contextual reason for
someone to click that
link also what it means is that there's
a lot less competition for that link
when my link is in that
article compare that with social news or
any type of social site you see when
you're on a social site and you're
looking at your social stream of
information there's a lot of different
people competing for your attention a
lot of different things and it's not
just in one subject area it's usually
from multiple subject areas and so the
context is very low because there's a
lot of different types of information
and the competition for your attention
is very high because of that people from
social sites or applications tend to
visit more often but they only tend to
view one page and leave immediately
because they're looking to see what was
interesting and then they move on to the
next
subject that's the difference between
how people react based on where they
come from and so when I'm measuring
links I'm looking to see which links do
I have what's the source and then how do
those sources behave differently from
one another and why you see if I find
that I'm getting links from sources that
people are staying longer doing more and
converting at a higher rate then I'm
going to continue to focus on building
links in those areas because it directly
affects how I monetize my
website so here's a strategy in building
links one of the things I'm looking at
is the source of links like I said if I
can find a link Source that's providing
visitors that will stay look at my
content engage with the content and
eventually convert and convert at a
higher rate than other sources of
content or visitors
then I'm going to focus on that source
and so I'm going to look at some high
Authority websites whether they're
industry Publications news sites
education sites those are what are
considered high Authority blogs articles
news
sites that's what I'm looking to do I
want to find the most authoritative
website and sometimes it happens
naturally if people that work at those
websites or manage those sites if they
find you and they like your content
they'll link to it and that way you can
get more credibility more
relevancy certain people certain
organizations certain websites have more
Authority and influence than others it
goes back to the question that I asked
you early in this module that how do you
know if someone is more authoritative
than somebody
else we also have mid Authority websites
which you can get some links on and low
Authority websites which are very easy
to get links but here's what I've
learned when it comes to link
building one link from one highquality
website can be worth hundreds or
thousands of mid to lowquality Links
ultimately it's about quality not
quantity one of the things that I will
do utilizing my link software is look at
the context of the link I want to see
how relevant this is so as I said if I
want to find a high relevant website
what I'm looking for in terms of this is
I want to see the influence of the
domain as well as the relevance of the
domain those are two factors that we're
going to look at when we're evaluating
the quality of a domain now as I'm
looking at this report here what
influence means is that it is a high
quality
website that within the linking
algorithm these sites have a lot of
authority however they may not be
relevant so for example they may have a
lot of sites attributing authority to
them but they may not be relevant to my
industry which is why we have the next
column of keyword relevance you see when
I'm evaluating my links I'm looking for
the sources
that are both influential and
relevant that means that I've got a link
from a site that fits the two standards
of high Authority it's authoritative and
relevant now it's good to have links
from authoritative sites that might not
be relevant it's still
authoritative however to get the full
benefit I want it to be influential and
relevant but but not to say that I'm not
looking for links from these other
sources this is just a means of
measuring what you have as well as
comparing it to your competitors and
other
websites now here's some best practices
when I'm optimizing anchor text I want
to maintain contextual relevance so I
want to use text in the text link and I
want to explain to people what they're
linking to what they're going to find
when they click on that link if I use an
image as a link I'm going to use an ALT
attribute because if that image doesn't
show up that Al tribute is necessary to
let people know where to go but also I
do get a little tiny bit of benefit by
using that alt attribute within the
image
link I also want to look at the
relevance of the source page that I'm
linking to and make sure contextually
the link the link text and and the
content of the page is contextually
relevant to the destination page I also
want to be sure that I don't overuse the
keywords that I don't make multiple
links to the same destination that I
don't use the same anchor text over and
over I can be downgraded or even
penalized by the search engine algorithm
if that is found on my
pages so as an example instead of using
click here for a how-to article I might
use the exact phrase of how to fix
whatever it is and use that as the link
to the page that has the
content that's a simple way of looking
at anchor text am I directing someone to
additional information if I am then how
can I present it to them so they know
exactly what they're going to find and
Link it
appropriately I look at as developing
the next step for your readers where do
you want them to go what do you want
them to do what resources do you have
available to them how can you structure
them so that they're easily understood
and you're explaining the Final
Destination like I said if you overuse
anchor text you can be downgraded or
penalized by the search engines so what
I will tell you to do is number one
avoid overstuffing anchor content that
means needlessly repeating keywords in
the anchor text don't do that avoid
being redundant meaning don't have four
or five or six links with the same
anchor text going to the same page
that's a clear way of letting search
engines know that you're going
overboard don't just randomly Place
links throughout your text just to get
the link ask yourself are you really
helping the reader find the information
they need and do it
once and then also avoid extremely
overly promotional words within the link
text such as best expert cheap number
one those types of things so a couple
examples we can say for travel advice
click here but I would say here is my
travel advice and Link travel advice
rewrite it be
creative if it were easy everyone would
be doing it but this is where you can
write things in a better way to get the
attention of the reader and position it
as a
resource also utilizing your url as the
link or as the anchor text as well for
the link in order to get that click as
I've got it here I would not recommend
that you use that I would recommend that
you avoid
that also the third line the check out
the best website for iPhones and iPhone
accessories utilizing overly promotional
words is one of those ways that you can
easily get caught by the search
engines now for future considerations
when it comes to Links realize that the
majority of algorithm changes are link
based evaluation refinements because
people are constantly attempting to fool
the search engines and develop a false
link
profile you should work to create high
quality links with high quality content
I wouldn't chase after Poor or
lowquality
links now as I've mentioned before there
are a number of tools available for you
to manage and measure your back links
tools such as link deck Moz Raven
Advanced Link manager Majestic SEO and
then also you can use your Google
analytics as well however Google
analytics only shows you the visitors
that have come from links and what
they've done the basic functions of Link
management software and there are many
other types other than what are listed
here but the first thing that it does is
just provide a catalog of incoming links
from other domains to your site and your
competitor sites they offer tools for
comparison to see which domains are
linking to you what type of link it is
and on which Pages those links are
listed they'll also report newly
acquired links in the past 30 60 90 days
or something similar to that the purpose
of Link management software is to help
you assess high quality domains versus
lowquality domains in terms of
importance and
relevance
like I said the first job of a link
management tool is to collect all of
your backlinks you add your domain and
the tools will usually spider the domain
they'll go out into search engines and
go out into many other formats in order
to find and retrace who is linking to
you what page that link is contained
sometimes what text is on that page and
what text is being used in the link they
will catalog all of your incoming links
organize them
format them and report back to you most
of these link programs provide
additional filters and management tools
so that you can get more insights about
who is linking to you how they are
linking to you and the type of
site personally I use Link decks in
order to Monitor and report on my
backlinking so the first report here
that I'm showing out of linkex is that I
see the total amount of incoming links
to my domain this says I have over 2,000
links and those 2,000 links are on about
1,000 domains on average it looks like I
have about two links from every domain
that is linking to me so this is one way
that you start to look at your links
number one the total amount of domains
that are linking to you and then the
total amount of links available this way
you can isolate domains that are linking
to you consistently and also find those
that may not be the best domains or that
are sending a lot of links that are just
not
relevant the next thing I do in
analyzing My Links is to look at the
type of Link meaning the type of site
that it's coming from this report breaks
down the amount of links coming from
blogs news sites directories forums
social sites articles or resources now
it doesn't usually get all of those
those links but it does get enough to
give you an idea of how well you're
doing in each channel one of the things
that I do like about this report is it
also has a timeline so I can look and
see when new links have been acquired
and maybe when some links have been just
disappeared that's called churn and it's
normal it's normal because many times a
link is published on social media and it
kind of just goes away or it's not
tracked anymore by your link management
software it can't find it anymore and so
linking is always Dynamic you are always
gaining new links and losing old links
there's going to be a normal amount of
churn the next report shows me all of
the domains that are linking to me it
also shows me in the next column how
many of those domains are also linking
to at least one competitor and it will
list as many competitors of I have
listed in here
if they list to multiple competitors it
will let me know the influence of that
site or the authority that site is seen
because of the amount of websites and
credibility that Authority has for that
domain it also let me know the keyword
relevance how relevant that website is
overall contextually to my domain and
the content that I have it will also let
me know how many pages on that domain
have links to my website so I can also
go through and I can filter this list by
the type of site I can filter by those
domains that are using anchor text to
see how much anchor text is being used
and what type of anchor text there are
many different ways that you can filter
through all of the domains that are
linking to you in order to get an idea
of what's happening on your domain what
are competitors doing and also the
relevance of the those links to your
site now when I say that I can add
competitors this is another type of
report very similar to the one I showed
earlier where I look at my own standing
in the different types of sources of
links such as blogs directories forums
and so on I can also when I add my
competitors look to see how they are
performing in those different areas as
well and so I can compare my link
profile to my competitors
different Industries are going to have
different backlink profiles they might
be more heavily weighted towards blogs
or they might be more heavily weighted
towards forums or social sites in this
way I can look to see if my competitors
are actively link building and how
they're going about it I can see where
maybe they are excelling in one area
that the rest of the competitors are not
so I can compare different strategies I
can also compare different timelines to
see if I am a acquiring Links at a
faster rate than my competitors this is
very important if you are a newer
business or a newer website trying to
compete now specifically what I can do
is look at an individual domain in this
case this domain has three pages linking
to me and that domain also links to two
of my competitors I can look at the
specific pages and what I'm looking at
here are Snippets this should be
familiar to you because what it's
showing is the URL of the page that's
linking to my page it shows me the page
title of that page and then in this
report it lets me know if there are any
keywords being used in the link in the
anchor text as well as the number of
links from that page now what this tells
me is that this is most likely a
directory something that is listing all
the different places that where you can
buy products because it's most likely
linking to the domain name seeing that
there are no keywords being used in
Anchor text and also that there are 16
outb about links from that page that
means that it must be a list of some
sort and they are linking not only to me
but most likely to competitors as well
so I can track my Links at the Domain
level and at the page level I can look
to see which Pages might have more
influence or relevance to my content I
can also see the link URL the page title
if any keywords are being used in the
anchor text and also within the context
of how many additional links are leaving
from that page if there are a high
amount of outgoing links on that page
then a link from that page might not be
as valuable since there are so many
links the less links there are coming
out from that page the more it will
benefit my site because I'm getting more
benefit from less
links now also what I'm going to do is
compare the link reports to my analytics
I'm going to go to my analytics because
linking software does not show traffic
it doesn't show how many people are
clicking on the link it only shows who's
linking to you but it does not show
visitor activity analytics will show you
visitor activity to see which domains
are most effective in sending visitors
to your site if you'll go back to the
primary benefits of linking visitors
branding and business analytics show me
visitors and business it shows me which
domains are sending me visitors and
which of those visitors are becoming
customers so what I can do is go to
Google analytics look at all the domains
that are referring traffic to my site I
can also click on the domain and see the
destination page P that they are linking
to I can see how many visitors are
coming either monthly or annually how
often they're coming back whether
they're new users or repeat users how
long they stay how many pages they View
and how many conversions as a result of
those visits this is a great way to get
a 360 Dee view of your linking because
not only do you want links that will
help you rank better you also want links
that will send business and customers to
you as
well building links can take many forms
ideally it is through networks
relationships and marketing that other
websites and users learn about you like
you and recommend you to others
unfortunately there is a lot of bad
outdated and untrustworthy advice to be
found about building links to your
website in this section I'll present the
best practices as accepted by the omcp
standard the objectives for this module
that you'll be able to develop a link
building strategy that you'll understand
the value of different link types
finally you'll be able to find inbound
link
opportunities the first step in building
links is to evaluate what you have now
there are many tools available that you
can utilize to do this for you
there are automated tools that you can
get that will catalog all of the
incoming links to your
website some of them are link deck MZ
Raven or Advanced Link manager there are
many that can do that you may also want
to utilize your analytics as well in
order to find websites that link to you
the first step is evaluating where you
are right now
your incoming links have a significant
impact on your rankings and you can do a
lot of onpage optimization and see some
results however a lot of Google's
algorithm takes into account links from
other high quality
websites now when you evaluate what you
have in this example I'm showing you a
screenshot from
linkex linkex cataloges the incoming
links to my website and it groups them
into different areas the first way it
groups them is by high value or high
influence
domains those are websites that link to
me that have a lot of influence not
necessarily in my industry but High
influence based on the amount of people
that link to them as an authority on
many different subjects the next way
that it groups that is based on
relevance now this is when it looks at
the match of my content versus the
content of the other website in the
first example we can see the National
Library of Medicine it is a high
influence website because it is a
government website with a lot of
information that is cited frequently
because of the amount of other websites
linking to that site it has a high
amount of
influence now based on the website that
I am
measuring there is a lot of keyword
relevance meaning that that National
Library of Medicine site with the
government has a lot of content that's
very similar to my site a lot of the
same keywords are being used so not only
is this website of high influence it
also has a lot of relevance and that's
key when evaluating my
backlinks I want to look at which
websites are also referring traffic so
while I may have a link from the
National Library of Medicine I went to
look at my analytics and look to see is
it also providing visitors are visitors
following that link to my site and I
also want to look at the quality of
traffic that it produces do these
visitors stay longer than average do
they conver more than average I want to
look at the quality of traffic based on
the
source next I want to look at the
incoming links from those other websites
number one I want to make sure that the
incoming link from the other site is
both accurate and relevant meaning the
text that is used in the link is it
accurate to the content that will appear
on the page when the visitor clicks that
link is the content relevant this is
especially relevant if I have updated my
website changed the content or moved
things around I want to be sure that
that incoming link sends visitors to the
appropriate page and the appropriate
information I also want to ensure that
that link is worded correctly that it
uses the right words that is sending
visitors and setting expectations of the
content that they will
see I may need to contact the website
manager or owner and maybe ask for a
better link text or a more accurate page
destination now this requires some
interaction with the owner or manager of
another website and you always want to
be respectful of their time and not
demanding that they make any changes in
some cases the organization may be so
big you may never find the right person
in order to optimize
the text or the destination of that link
you always want to look for accuracy in
cases where your company or website name
is utilized in the link but also if
there is any contact information such as
address phone number a description of
your business and any content make sure
it's accurate and it all points to the
right
place another way to look for links is
to Simply go to a search engine and
start doing searches search for your
company your business your company name
and look for websites that may mention
you but do not have a live link to your
website many times your company will be
mentioned or cited but there will not be
a live link you can only find these
through doing searches and seeing which
websites mention you without linking to
you now this could be an opportunity to
get an Easy Link especially if you can
find some contact information and
finding the right person that could add
a link to your company
information again you'll need to be
polite ask for their help and it will
help it if you can develop the link
along with the link text and send that
over giving them just a quick and easy
edit to be able to add the information
so make it as easy as
possible as an example I've provided a
sample request
format again you want to be polite you
want to be inviting and respectful of
their time and their
management sometimes like I said you may
find the right person that can help you
however the larger the company the more
difficult it will be to make this happen
this just requires your patience and
again being polite and not expecting the
company to do what you are asking many
times this is just a formality and
sometimes companies will act on it so be
sure to approach this with the right
expectations the next thing I want to
look at are business listings these are
the easy ways to establish links and
ensure that links are where they should
be and also o
opportunities look for business
directories especially if your company
has a local presence you can utilize
Chamber of Commerce lists Association
lists or local listings if they are on
websites see if they offer links that
can go to your website rather than just
the list of businesses that are in the
area even on a larger level you can look
for associations directories or listings
where you can add your business or
double check if your business is there
and always ensure that your business
name address phone number and URL are
correct complete and consistent with
other
listings the next level will require
some active marketing and that's where
you search for
opportunities you can go out and look
for other resource lists within your
industry
or directories of businesses within your
industry and you can get a link many
times through membership or submitting
your business as a
resource however you may want to step up
your marketing you can do that by
interviewing your clients seeing if they
might be willing to provide a
testimonial and a link to your website
you may also want to go out and find
other communities online maybe some
social communities that are relevant to
your
industry get involved with those
communities fill out a profile and get
involved by contributing information by
sharing information you'll find that
people like getting information and
they'll respond by linking to your
site another option is to utilize the
tool that you had for indexing your
links from the first step you can also
add your competitors and you can look at
their back links
you can look and see which websites and
which domains are linking to your
competitors but you always need to go
and see why what are those other sites
linking to and what is the nature of
that link sometimes it may exclude you
from being able to approach competitors
back links and ask them for
links however if they're being linked to
by companies that are simply stating
here are vendors in this space and they
are linking your competitors and you're
not there then it might make a lot of
sense for you to approach and ask if you
can be listed as well however be sure
that the links to your competitors are
not from a consumer or customer
relationship in that case it might be
out of line for you to ask for a link
make sure if you approach anyone who's
linking to a competitor and asking for a
link to your site
make sure the context is right and that
it makes sense for them and that's the
ultimate judge of value does it benefit
somebody else to link to your site we
all know that it will benefit you but
when you present your link request you
need to offer value and a benefit for
others to link to you so be sure that
you present it in a way that is
beneficial and good for those people
that will be adding the link they're the
ones that have to take the work to do it
and they're also the ones that are
adding a recommendation for you and your
business so as always you need to be
considerate and
patient now the best way to build links
is by creating something that people
like and sharing it you see the best way
to build links is by creating value
through content or information or
entertainment you see when people like
things they link to it if they find a
study or a white paper or research that
you performed they link to it if you
post a infographic that explains
something and it's attractive people
link to it you see that's what's most
amazing about linking I find that when
we put most of our effort into creating
content that people like that's what
builds the most valuable and the most
relevant links and so what type of
content well you can create infographics
videos top 10 lists or articles articles
with advice or analysis of Market data
or even
research that type of content people
love it and so when you publish it out
you utilize social media to extend the
reach and the visibility of that type of
content and when someone likes it
they'll link to it and recommend it to
others now people also like depending
upon your industry or your business they
also like some personality maybe some
humor people always like expert
information they like the cute this is
why pictures of cats tend to be liked
and linked to more than almost anything
else and also the
unexpected if you can inject any of that
into your content that just makes it
more valuable more personable and again
more sharable by other people and every
time someone shares it it builds a link
to your
site you see the best linking is when
people like something when you create
something that people like and share you
might be surprised at the many
opportunities there are to get links
based on your content I've seen many
many blogs based on cooking fashion Arts
Sports music and when people specialize
within a specific topic they always find
an audience and so anything they publish
builds links even on certain social
media sites such as Pinterest people
upload pictures on articles and in inog
Graphics especially about landscaping
flowers food cars you name it there is a
special interest for anything and you
can develop links from those social
sites to your site and it can generate
traffic even with a Blog developing
articles that talk about upcoming events
new music Sports whatever it is when you
create content that people
like it takes the longest amount of time
to build content for building links when
you develop your own content that's the
biggest investment you'll make in time
and research and writing and
presentation however the result is that
when you develop that content you will
receive the best and highest quality
links and the most valuable links are
going to be to that content as I
mentioned before one high quality link
can be worth more than hundreds or
thousands of lowquality links so my best
advice is to create content that people
like that they link to and that will be
high value links that you'll generate to
your site so if you are looking to
become an Su professional then look no
further than simply learn postgraduate
program in digital marketing find the
cost Link in description box for more
information optimizing technical
elements of a website such that search
engines can easily crawl and index the
web pages is known as technical
SEO some technical optimizations include
reducing the page loading speed of a web
page to a
minimum submitting site maps to search
engines have organized website structure
as it informs search engines about the
essential pages of the
website adding redirections for the
deleted URLs or temporarily moving
URLs identify duplicate content and
replace it with unique content before I
tell you how to bring traffic to your
website let me tell you why this is so
important okay why do we want to bring
users to our website I mean it has to be
on equal ground as web development and
design is somebody who goes to your site
and does something when they get to your
site so you have users and when those
users get to your site they're
generating page views and traffic and
you want to turn that traffic into
engagement okay so each Page's traffic
is configured independently of all their
pages so when you go when somebody goes
to your website they look at a page
that's a page view and certain pages on
your website you want to turn that page
view into a conversion okay whether that
be you know looking at a video or
purchasing something so think of these
pages on your website as salespeople
they're trying to convert visitors who
come to your website but first we need
to get the visitors to your website so
when you get visitors to your website
again you can generate sales which means
revenue or you can increase brand
awareness or you can earn Revenue
through sponsored post and advertisement
so if you have for example a lot of
content on your website you can turn
that in to revenue by hosting ads on
your website so when somebody clicks on
that ad you're going to earn a
percentage of that click okay what that
click is worth so having a website means
a lot of good things for you but first
you got to get the traffic there and so
what we're going to do is we're going to
tell you how to drive traffic to your
website so there's lots of different
ways in which you can bring traffic to
your website well the first is paid
advertising so paying to advertise your
products services with ads is one of the
easiest ways to drive traffic to your
website so some of the options available
are search ads social media ads or
display ads so search ads are ads that
are displayed in the search engine
results so when a user types in a
keyword query you want your ad to show
up based on that keyword query okay so
an example is digital marketing course
somebody types in digital marketing
course and simply learn is the first ad
that shows up how do we know it's an ad
because you could see the word add next
to the domain so when somebody clicks on
that link simply learn is going to pay
Google so that's how search advertising
works okay the next is social so social
media marketing involves increasing
traffic or engagement or brand awareness
or lots of different strategies but
you're instead of doing this on search
you're doing it on a social media
platform okay so for example you can
adver ize on any particular platform and
the way you advertise could be with an
image it could be with a video so in
this case you could see Cobo is doing a
sponsored ad here how to succeed with
Google ads and then another form of
advertising is display so display means
creating ads that are placed on specific
websites so with display unlike search
you have a choice in the ad format with
search you only have text but with
display you have text Adge image ads
rich media ads video ads so you have
lots of different options in which you
can advertise on other websites so the
idea here is to get your ad in front of
the Right audience when they could see
your display Banner your banner ad then
it's going to be more visual more
appealing generate some brand interest
and hopefully you can get somebody to
click on that ad and over to your
website so that's paid average izing
again through search through social
through display but you can also promote
your site on social media so once your
content is gone live you could take
advantage of different social media
platforms I mean it really depends on
what you're trying to promote because
what you're trying to promote needs to
align with the appropriate social media
platform so Facebook is best suited for
Industries like food and Beverages and
news and media and if you're selling a
product so you fall under one of those
categories reason Facebook could be the
right platform for you if you're
involved in again beauty or food and
beverage or e-commerce then you can also
leverage Instagram which is part of
Facebook's ecosystem so if you advertise
on Facebook you can also advertise on
Instagram Andor Instagram so it doesn't
have to be and Facebook and Instagram it
could be Facebook or Instagram you also
have LinkedIn as a platform LinkedIn is
great for B2B so if you're trying to
promote industry news or or tips and
best practices or job postings then
LinkedIn is the place for you it's a B2B
platform it's great for targeting
specific Industries targeting specific
job levels or job descriptions okay so
LinkedIn is great if you're into B2B
focusing on the business side of it so
you also have YouTube now YouTube is
part of Google's ecosystem YouTube is a
video platform okay so it's great if
you're trying to promote gaming or
entertainment if you're a vlogger okay
so YouTube's a great way to promote your
site uh by getting your product out
there in the form of a video then you
have Twitter Twitter to me encompasses a
lot of different Industries Beauty and
fitness news and media entertainment
okay you have limited number of
characters but a lot of people are
active on Twitter and it's a great way
to generate some awareness and get some
clicks over to your website so these are
just some of the most popular social
media platforms of course there are
plenty more out there the third way in
which you can drive traffic to your site
is guest post blogging so most of you
already know what blogging is all about
well if you're blogging for your own
site you can jump on somebody else's
site and blog on their behalf so having
the opportunity to guess post on another
website can be very helpful because one
that other blog could have lots of
traffic and have a a well-known brand so
if you're blogging on another blog it's
going to build your brand awareness and
potentially increase traffic to your
blog or website so it exposes to you to
targeted traffic so if you're going to
guest blog guest blog on a site that's
very relevant to your business or
industry that way you're targeting the
Right audience okay you can expand your
personal Network so getting yourself out
there getting your brand out there in
front of a different audience and then
and then obviously for serfs because it
generates a backlink so serfs search
engine ranking Pages means that hey if
you want to rank organically you're
going to have to generate some backlinks
so guest blogging is an a way to
generate some backlinks to your site and
an effect that's going to help you get
your pages ranked higher because
Google's going to recognize the
relationship from one blog to your blog
and build up your relevancy so some
other benefits here here to guest
blogging is you grow your social media
PL following because you can then
promote that on social media that you're
guest blogging okay again you can
improve your online Authority okay
because when you're guest blogging and
you have recognition on that guest blog
if it's a popular blog then that's going
to help your domain and Page Authority
for SEO and then the end result is going
to improve your back blink score so
there a lot of benefits to guest
blogging to me at the end of the day
it's just about reaching out to your
audience using another platform to do
that in the form of a Blog and the
results of that is going to mean more
brand awareness for you in turning that
traffic from that other blog into
qualified leads so you can also
interview industry thought leaders so
that's another way an interesting way to
generate traffic to your sites so
reaching out to thought leaders for
interviews okay could generate some
credibility for you and the other person
so it's reciprocal so it means that
you're active in the industry that
you're in and it allows you to engage
with other leaders in the industry and
the indirect net result of that could be
increased traffic because if you do the
interview and you record it or if it's
via video then you can obviously post it
on other platforms and that could in
turn Drive traffic to your website
obviously just like guest blogging it's
going to increase your reach so getting
yourself out there nobody knows who your
brand is and they know know who the
thought leaders are and they see you're
interviewing the thought leaders then
that's going to put you in front of
these people and so it's going to
increase your reach another way to drive
traffic to your website is just to make
sure your website's responsive and what
do we mean by responsive well we mean
does it work on multiple devices
specifically mobile so depending on the
device your website hides shows shrinks
enlarges or moves content so that it can
form to the browser that that person's
looking at on your for your website so
if somebody's looking on mobile at your
website you want to make sure that your
website adjust accordingly so you want
to be able to you know test and make
sure it's responsive and so it's content
range based on importance okay does it
work across different browsers on
different devices and do the images text
and everything else align just like it
does on desktop so there are plenty of
tools out there on the web all you need
to do is just do a search for you know
check my website for responsiveness you
know so you you can use plenty of tools
to check to see if your website is
responsive towards multiple devices why
is that important because if somebody
goes to your website Via Mobile and your
site doesn't align properly or the
content's all stretched out and somebody
has to maneuver their browser just to
see your website then chances are
they're not going to come back chances
are they're not even going to convert
okay so you want to be able to revise
your device browser combinations you
want to make sure that everything works
accordingly you want to be able to test
those fonts make sure they look good and
then you also want to make sure that
people can navigate so if they're on
mobile are they going to navigate just
as easy as they can on desktop and if
you have any popups you want to probably
make sure they're removed so that way
when somebody's looking at your website
they're not getting interfered with on
mobile and then of course you want to
make sure that these Pages load okay so
they load just as quick on desktop as
they should on mobile and vice versa so
they should not take a long time to load
so moving on from responsiveness I'm
mobile to building a brand community so
brand community refers to a group of
people who identify your brand and use
your brand as a platform to exchange
ideas and contribute content some
advantages of any brand Community are
promoting brand evangelism and loyalty
it could be a source of feedback loyalty
and ideas so build a community build a
brand Community who you know identify
with you okay so continue to you know
treat these people as loyal customers
okay maybe give them a promotion uh to
use specifically just for them that they
can use on your website or talk directly
to them because you know that they're
followers they repeat customers they
purchase for you multiple times so talk
to them differently as well you know who
these people are and that's what
building a Brand's all about it's about
identifying your brand with other people
okay and identify people who identify
with your brand and messaging and
talking to them as if they're part of
your own Community your own family so
you can use user generated content that
provides future marketing strategies so
the feedback you get from your own
Community could be in turn used to
promote or used in future marketing
strategies I.E advertising I.E post on
social okay can also provide PR
opportunities so it's a chance for you
to you know put out press releases based
on the community that you built so any
brand regardless of who it is should be
able to identify with your audience
their target audience and that target
audience eventually going going to
become part of a community these are
group of people who identify with you
what you're trying to sell what your
cause is what your mission statement is
what your service is they identify with
you so leverage them and reciprocate
identify them talk to them separately
give them the what they deserve the
respect and loyalty that they deserve as
well because they're communicating and
they're following you as a brand so the
next thing you could do to Drive traffic
is Be Active in the comment section so
engage in relevant and thought-provoking
conversations on other blogs and sites
it doesn't necessar have to be another
blog per se it could be other sites like
Reddit or cor or medium sites that have
a lot of content that are broken out by
industry that allow you to engage in
conversation allow you to either up Vote
or share or respond okay so be active
because when you're active people are
going to see that hey you're a leader in
the industry you know what you're
talking about you have some some brand
Equity you have some thought and some
knowledge on this specific topic and
subject so it just puts you in a better
light when you can respond and be active
on these different platforms okay let's
turn our attention to search engine
optimization also known as SEO or
organic search so in order to drive
traffic to your site you going to have
to implement an SEO strategy why do you
want to implement an SEO strategy
because it can help you improve your
overall searchability and visibility on
search engines and obviously that comes
with advantages one of those advantages
is obviously more traffic to the site
search is still King in terms of volumes
of people using search on a daily basis
so you have a great opportunity to be
found it also builds trust and
credibility because still still a
majority of the people who do a search
click on an organic search listing and
so if you're found organically and
you're ranked number one then chances
are somebody's going to click on your
listing and it provides increased
engagement in traffic and so what that
means is more traffic more engagement
and engagement is something you define
it could be again a download of a
document or the clicking on the play
button of a video or or submitting a
form or signing up for a newsletter or
calling these are all forms of
Engagement so the amount of traffic you
drive from organic search to your
website is only going to improve
engagement okay so you can also provide
an improve user experience and what do
we mean by that well if you're getting
lots of traffic from organic search you
have a really good opportunity to do ab
testing and when you do AB testing you
can improve user experience meaning
you're showing one variation against the
other from people coming from organic
search and so this is helpful and that
you know if you're running an AB test
the variation has a chance to improve or
outperform the original and if it
outperforms the original you're
improving user experience and then it
helps Target quality traffic so SEO to
me or all search is the only medium in
which you're meeting somebody halfway
you're you're addressing what they're
looking for so if somebody's looking for
a pair of red women's Nike shoes the
2019 model and you have that particular
product to offer well you have a chance
of showing up via organic search
somebody types in you know women's red
Nike shoes size whatever at the year
2019 model then of course they're going
to probably likely click on your listing
because you have what they're looking
for and and that goes with any keyword
any industry any business any segment
any type of product you're selling so
again you have a chance to really be
visible for what people are looking for
and so that's the beauty of search
engine optimization you have a really
good opportunity here to meet people
halfway to drive quality traffic to get
them to enjoy a good user experience all
the while generating engagement and
along with SEO we want to be able to
build backlink so SEO is a two-pronged
approach meaning you have two strategies
in one on page and off page and so off-
page involves backlinking so back links
are just links that direct users from
other websites to your own website so
with that inherently it's going to drive
traffic qualified traffic to your
website because if somebody's on a
relevant website that's linking to yours
and they click on that link and go to
your website it's likely going to be
qualified meaning they're going to be
relevant and so backlinking because it's
an off-page strategy why is it an
off-page SCS strategy because if Google
craws that other site that has a link to
you then that's going to give you credit
because Google say hey this site's
getting some links from some relevant
sites we must think they're relevant and
therefore we're going to trust this site
so by Google trusting your site it's
going to improve your organic ranking
and with the organic rankings being
improved approv D meaning it's going to
mean faster indexing so what does that
mean so you want to be indexed by the
search engines and so the quicker Google
can find your pages even if it's on
somebody else's site then that means
they're going to follow that link go to
that page on your site and take that
page back to their servers to be indexed
okay so the quicker you can get indexed
the quicker you can get found and then
it helps with referral traffic so again
we noticed that our efforts are on SEO
organic search but if you're getting
traffic from another website hey that
still counts that's referral traffic
okay so that's a side advantage to
having backlinks is good traffic from
other sites okay so those those are
inherently the some of the reasons to do
backlinking okay never hurts I mean
there's brand awareness reasons to being
on other sites as well there's industry
leadership meaning if you you you post
content on Reddit okay you're coming
across as an industry leader but yet
generating a back blink which helps with
SEO and referral traffic so there's a
lot of benefits to building backlinks
and the opposite of backlinks are
internal links so you want to do
internal linking and that just means
connecting one page on your site to
another and why is that beneficial
because it can help direct visitors to
other Pages they wouldn't normally
otherwise find via your navigation so if
you're active on a Blog don't be afraid
to include multiple internal links you
want to move people through your site
you want the flow of traffic to go from
one page to another to another and so
when you do internal linking just like
with backlinks it's going to improve the
indexing of your website Google's going
to follow those links and index those
pages and Google does give credit from
an SEO perspective from an internal
linking perspective so if one page is
linked to another and that page has
really good relevance in the eyes of
Google then the other page is probably
going to benefit from that the other
reason you want to do internal linking
again you want to move people from your
one page of your site to the other and
when you do that it's going to reduce
bounce rat so bounce rate is simply the
rate at which people land on a page and
then leave so if I have 100 people land
on my homepage and only one person went
to another page and the other 99 left
the site then that's a 99% bounce rate
so by putting internal links in place
you're helping people move from one page
to the other and thus reducing the
bounce rate and that's what you want you
want to keep people on your site you
want to be greedy it also drives traffic
to older post so again when we say older
post we're really referring to blog post
so if you have a relevant blog post and
you're writing a new blog post then link
the two together if it's relevant link
it I don't you know regardless of how
old it is you know you want to show
Google that these older blog posts just
because they were written a year ago
doesn't mean they're outdated and old
fashioned okay or useless you want to
keep them alive by linking to them so to
me that's a good strategy for internal
linking link to older blog posts you
know show people you're an industry
expert you've been doing this for a
while and then you have lots of content
to share okay so the longer you can keep
somebody on your website the more likely
it is they're going to engage and
convert and some other inherent benefits
improves page rank so what we mean by
Page rank is simply just a rank that
Google gives pages so the more internal
linking you have the better off you are
and then it helps spread link juice
across websites and what we mean by link
juice again just like back linking it
builds relevancy so just keep all these
inherent benefits in mind to internal
linking the end result is keeping the
flow of traffic on your site and all
these other benefits will fall into
place okay so another way in which you
can really hone in on traffic to your
website is longtail keywords and
longtail wordss to me are more than just
one or two keyword phrases okay so
they're usually three or longer keywords
in a phrase okay so longtail keywords
really nowadays account for most web
searches people really take the time to
even Poe questions as a search query say
likely somebody it's unlikely somebody's
going to go into search and just type in
the word shoes they might type in red
shoes but that's unlikely what they're
probably going to type in is is you know
red Nike running shoes
2019 or some variation of that okay
that's a longtail keyword and some of
the advantages of using longtail
keywords to be found for are less
competition so if you're using broad
keywords like red shoes then who doesn't
want to be found for Red Shoes well you
don't necessarily you don't want to be
found for red shoes because it's too
broad you don't know what type of shoes
somebody's looking for you just know
they're looking for red shoes it could
be running shoes it could be work shoes
it could be you know boots it could be
slippers okay it's too broad so long
tail keywords help narrow it in and the
more narrow and focused a keyword is the
less competition is going to have and
when something's not competitive in the
form of a keyword then that means your
chances of ranking for that keyword are
going to be greater and the chances of
you ranking faster are going to be
greater and then of course if somebody's
looking for exactly what you have to
offer then you have a higher chance to
convert that that person so if you have
exactly those
2019 red Nike women's running shoes and
somebody does a search for that and
that's a longtail keyword and they click
on your organic listing if you have the
right price then they're probably going
to convert so you have a really good
chance of converting somebody using
longtail keywords so my point here is if
you're looking for keywords to use focus
on longer tail don't focus on one or two
keyword phrases what it also does is
brings targeted traffic so even if
somebody doesn't convert hey they could
be back because it's exactly what
they're looking for and if you're
focusing on longer tail keywords like I
just mentioned stay away from the
shorter ones it's just easier to
optimize your page for SEO so remember
SEO is a two-pronged approach on page
and off page we talked about off-page
with internal linking and backlinks on
page is all about making sure those
keywords you choose are integrated in
with the page you want to be found for
and so if you're using a longtail
keyword it's just easy to work that
keyword in so it enables easier onpage
optimization okay let's switch away from
SEO to email marketing so let's focus on
email marketing as a form or method of
driving traffic to your website so email
marketing has been around a long time in
terms of digital marketing why because
it provides an effective way to convert
leads into sales why because you can
send personalized email emails to a
target audience so when you send an
email to somebody on a regular basis you
know who that person is so what are you
doing in the email you're writing a
specific message to that person well
email marketing is the same thing except
you're just sending an email to a larger
group of people and when you send an
email to a larger group of people you're
still going to personalize the message
right you're not going to send a generic
email to 1,000 people okay nobody's
going to do that so make make sure your
email is targeted and if it's targeted
it could be cost effective why because
sending large amounts of emails or let's
just say an email to a large amount of
people or a large group of people is
going to be cost effective it's not cost
per click you know it's not C per open
okay so email usually depending on the
the email provider you're using really
is a flat fee so it just really depends
on how many emails you're sending or how
how many people you're sending the email
too as well so but email generally tends
to be more cost effective than other
forms of marketing so look at the email
content provider you're using and just
get a sense of what they charge but if
you look at it and do a comparison email
generally is cheaper than say doing
paperclick because with paperclick
you're paying for each click okay so
that could be expensive depending on the
keywords so email marking is also
timesaving okay meaning it's a one-time
thing and done so once you send the the
email it's just a matter of you know
watching and looking at the metrics and
learning what's going on so you don't
make the same mistakes again but it is
time conducive meaning you send out one
email and that's it with payperclick
you're constantly measuring and managing
the campaigns and it provides real-time
marketing so when you do send the email
more than likely majority of the people
on day one or the day you send the email
are going to be able to view it open it
click on some of the links and convert
so that's normally what happens in email
majority of the people open it on day
one and it kind of tails off from there
so think about it as real time so when
you send that email and if you have a
thousand people on your email recipient
list break it up send the first 500
first with a different subject line and
then you can see the data come in and if
you don't see the good results from the
subject line or the body of the email or
you know the page you're going to then
make it just adust Ms before you send
the other email to the next 500 so
that's a great thing about emails you
can break up the email into two groups
the first group and then the second
group with different subject lines and
you can probably send them a little bit
of time apart that way you can learn
from the first email because with email
you are generally going to get results
right away okay within the first 24
hours so that's a great thing about
email okay so the other thing about
email it's less intrusive so normally
people who are going to get the email
are the ones who sign up for the email
so they're almost expecting your email
so when they get your email again as
long as you're not sending an email on a
daily basis normally most companies send
it monthly or bi-weekly it's not going
to be as intrusive okay and then it also
helps build credibility increase
visibility and brand awareness meaning
you're going to build your brand in that
email you're going to put content in
that email that's going to show off your
credibility meaning you could put some
testimonials in the email you can put
some good affiliations you can put a
good article to an industry article you
just wrote so email is going to
inherently continue to build brand
awareness for you okay and it's an easy
way to track Roi so if you're e
e-commerce it's pretty clear you send
the email somebody opens it clicks on it
checks out and purchases something it's
easily trackable because you could track
it right from that email so one thing I
want to say there is just if you do send
an email make sure you're tracking that
campaign and you want to be able to use
an analytics program like Google
analytics okay if you use Google
analytics you're going to be able to
track when you send the email who clicks
on it and who converts so you want to be
able to measure an Roi for these emails
and you can and that's the beauty of
email marketing okay let's move away
from email marketing to webinars so
webinars great method for Effective
social media promotion it's a great
great way to bring traffic to your
website so why do we recommend webinars
well because it provides direct content
contact within your target group what do
we mean by contact with your target
group well you're going to host a
webinar and you're going to invite this
targeted group of people who are
interested in your product or service so
if you have a Facebook Community you
could do a Facebook live event or you
could do a YouTube or you know you can
even set up a webinar on another
platform promote it on social media and
if you're promoting something on social
media you're probably promoting it to
people who are already following you or
like you and so that's what we mean by
direct contact with your target group
you're you're going to be able to create
a webinar and talk directly to that
group and that's going to help build
brand awareness and credibility and the
great thing about webinars is you don't
need some fancy software I mean I'm
talking to you on a webinar right now
and so webinars are free all all you
need is a video camera and a recorder
that's all and that's all built in with
software so there's plenty of software
out there that allows you just to do a
webinar really quick and easy there's
lots of opportunities in software so and
a lot of them are very cost effective so
if you want to build uh create a webinar
you can do that by spending very little
money and webinars again allow you to
talk to your targeted group your
community maybe prospective clients it
helps build credibility
and in effect Drive traffic to your
website and when somebody does attend a
webinar they're likely going to be
highly engaged because you're inviting
them they're going to opt into the
webinar and the great thing about
webinars is even if they don't attend
the webinar the day you have it it's
going to be recorded so they can always
go back and watch it so whoever watches
the webinar is going to be engaged
because it's going to be a topic they're
interested in and then users are likely
to become prospective customers so
having a webinar talking about something
inherently interesting to maybe a larger
group of people you can promote that on
social media and potentially get
prospective customers to sign up and
watch the webinar and if you do they're
going to be engaged and then take the
next step oh I like what this guy this
person has to say they seem to be
credible I like their personality I like
their brand I like their product I'm
going to go check their web out their
website Okay so webinars allow you to
kind of pull in more people as well as
just your community because you can
promote the webinar and you can promote
it in advance and you can leverage
social media for that okay so something
related to webinars incorporating video
content so videos have been proven to be
a really good way to attract new
visitors and it just it makes your
website very engaging when you have
videos on your website as well so if you
create video you have an opportunity to
posted on various video platforms like
YouTube or vomo okay there's plenty of
video platforms out there or just
embedded in a blog post or embedded in a
Facebook post or a tweet okay so you can
do a lot with video and having video on
your site is going to increase
engagement okay when you increase
engagement good things happen that's
going to lead to increased conversions
in sales or or Roi or just like we
mentioned the webinar get help build
trust with your audience so even that
webinar you could post on your website
so you want people to engage by watching
this video they watch the video they're
going to gain trust in you because
you're talking directly to that person
that user that audience that visitor to
your website and when you get build
trust it's going to increase engagement
and that's the beauty of video unlike
text or imagery videos really do engage
with the audience and so the more video
you could do the better off you are
because again you can leverage social to
draw attention to your brand and product
and service and then you can have that
video on your website to increase
engagement which in turn increases
conversions and sales and improves Roi
so always think video there's plenty of
video software out there that you can
leverage and the great thing about video
too is hey most people are using mobile
phones these days smartphones and so
video works just as well on mobile as it
does on desktop so keep that in mind you
know video is going to be engaging
regardless of what device somebody uses
and then of course if they're watching
the video on Facebook or YouTube then it
chances are they're going to share that
particular video which is going to bode
well for your brand and traffic okay so
video if somebody likes a video it's
very easy to share video especially from
a mobile phone so YouTube just makes it
so easy to share or like or subscribe to
to a channel it just it becomes that
much easier things can go viral and
chances of them going viral with video
are going to be greater okay so other
ways to drive traffic to your website is
submit your content to content
aggregators so what's a Content
aggregator well a content aggregators is
like Reddit that provides a great
platform for you to post your content so
that's what a Content aggregator is
really a site like Reddit or medium or
Kora where you could post content to a
large number of people okay so with
Reddit people are either going to up
vote it or down vote it so the more
upvotes you get or thumbs up or likes or
people who encourage that content the
more of a chance it has to be found and
so first thing out of the gate if you do
provide content to a Content aggregator
like Reddit make sure it's good quality
content that's interesting and that
should be a case the case across the
board whether it's a a social post or
blog post make sure the content's unique
professional and interesting and then if
you do say put something on medium or
you do put something on Kora and it is
professional and interesting and thought
provoking then people are going to react
to it and then that again could lead to
traffic but even if it doesn't lead to
traffic it helps build brand awareness
so if you have content just like videos
leverage it put the content out there
okay when you put content out there it's
only going to especially if it's good
content put it's going to put you in a
good light so don't be afraid to share
your content on the likes of Reddit or
medium or core or some of these other
content aggregator websites because good
things are only going to happen and
again referral traffic SEO brand
awareness conversions so all these are
inherent benefits of just sharing your
content okay and then finally we want to
learn from analytics okay so what do we
mean learning from analytics so there
plenty of analytics platforms out there
one of of the most popular is Google
analytics so you want to make sure
you're tracking traffic on your site
with Google analytics so all you have to
do is just go to Google analytics via
search sign up add the analytics code to
your website and waa they're doing all
the heavy lifting they're going to track
traffic coming to your website and not
only they going to track traffic but
they're going to tell you how that
traffic engaged and so the benefits of
it Google analytics is hey you could
figure out where users are coming from
are they coming from that email campaign
that I sent out to a thousand people are
they coming from YouTube based on that
video I posted or are they coming from
Reddit based on the content I just
posted there or they coming from organic
search it so Google analytics can help
us understand how much traffic we're
getting from organic search so it to
help us measure our SEO efforts and then
with Google analytics you could segment
so we could segment by mobile we can
segment by desktop returning user new
user by campaign by Page by Language by
city by region I mean there's so many
ways in which to segment your audience
and segmenting simply is breaking up the
entire group of people who come to your
website into different segments based on
what you want to see so if you want to
look at you know females between the
ages of 18 to 24 who come from mobile
via organic search that's a segment and
you can look at that information and
analytics if that's your target audience
then you could see how they're
performing okay so an there are a lot of
benefits to Google analytics definitely
want to take advantage of segmenting in
Google analytics you could look at your
competition so there's a benchmarking
report the great thing about Google
analytics you can also look at content
and how your content's performing once
somebody lands on your website are they
what page are they spending time on what
page are they engaging on the most okay
what pages have the highest bounce rate
or the lowest time on page so you can
really determine what pages work best
and then of course the end result in
analyzing all this data is you want to
be able to find- tune your website so
take advantage of the data that Google
analytics or any other analytics
platform is given you by learning once
you learn what's going on with your
website you can make adjustments to your
website to improve user experience okay
so we went over a lot of different ways
to drive traffic okay you can
incorporate all this to your website
immediately let's talk about that
keyword research for a website with
shoes and and it doesn't really matter
what particular product you have if you
need to rank number one on Google it all
starts with the keywords as I mentioned
before and so in this example if you
have a website where you sell shoes for
kids you're going to want to be found
for certain keywords so so the obvious
keyword here would be shoes for kids
well every key word that you target has
search volume associated with it so that
means when we talk about search volume
we're talking about how many people on
average type in that keyword or related
keyword on google.com or Google search
and there's always an average number of
searches associated with every keyword
and we call that search volume how much
search volume so obviously if we're
going to Target a keyword we want to
have as much volume as possible however
there's always going to be competition
for those keywords meaning there's
always going to be other websites who
want to rank number one on Google for
the same keywords and we call that
competition or difficulty so for every
keyword you're going to have volume and
you're going to have competition or
difficulty and the difficulty ranges as
well depending on the tool you use and
we'll get into that in a minute but but
search volume is how much on average
people are typing in that keyword or
close variance of that keyword and the
difficulty is measured in terms of how
many other websites are trying to rank
for the same keyword and so ideally when
it comes to keyword research we want to
find that nice balance we want high
volume and we want low competition but
at the same time we want to focus on
keywords that are highly relevant to our
business business so if we're selling
shoes for kids and shoes for kids is
highly relevant has high volume and low
competition then that's a keyword we
want to Target so we always want to
focus in on those three areas so there's
always a tradeoff with keywords so shoes
for kids might have high volume but also
might have high competition or
difficulty if we look for another
keyword that's just as relevant for
example shoes for children it may still
have high search volume volume but the
competition or the difficulty may be
lower and if that's the case then that
may be a better keyword for us to Target
instead of something highly competitive
like shoes for kids we can focus on
another relevant keyword like shoes for
children with just as much volume and
lower competition and the reason why we
want lower competition is because we
want to be able to rank for that keyword
so the higher the competition the harder
it is for us to rank number one on
Google for that keyword and so the whole
idea Beyond keyword research is
analyzing and choosing the best keywords
so we want to identify a list of
keywords that are always relevant we
want to choose the keyword that your
competitors are ranking for and we want
to use thirdparty tools to choose
keywords to identify which keywords have
low competition and what keywords have
high search volume so one thing to take
into consideration when you're doing
keyword research is is that the longer
the keyword phrase or in other words
longtail keywords or keywords with three
keywords in the phrase or more you're
going to always have less competition
but there's always a tradeoff with
longtail keywords meaning the longer the
keyword phrase there's going to be less
volume but the trade-off is less
competition and so what we want to do is
we want to brainstorm some ideas and
find those relevant keywords so let's
look at an example here so if we go to
Google ads so Google ads has a tool
called Keyword Planner and let's just
say I have a a website where I'm selling
dried figs and if I'm selling dried figs
I want people to buy these dried figs
however in order to attract them I want
to be able to show them that hey we have
a a bunch of recipes and if I show you a
bunch of recipes where you can use dried
figs maybe you'll buy these dried figs
to using these recipes recipes and so
we're going to look for keywords related
to bread recipes because if we can
optimize for our recipes page for bread
then that will attract an audience who
wants to make bread and use dried figs
with those bread recipes so that's the
example I'm going to give here and so if
I look at the Keyword Planner in Google
ads if I just type in bread recipes what
Google is going to do is they're going
to give me an average monthly search
volume so I can see the average monthly
search volume here is 60,500 and so in
order to do keyword research what I
would recommend is keep a spreadsheet
and so the idea behind the spreadsheet
is to document the volume and the
competition you're getting for certain
keywords so if I go into a spreadsheet
here my theme of keywords is bread
recipes my keyword is bread recipes and
my volume therefore is going to be
60,500
however if I go back into Google's
Keyword Planner Google's telling me the
competition is low so that's great I
want high volume I want low competition
but how low is low so we want to be
careful so if we're going to put in
numbers into a spreadsheet we want to
figure out what that competition really
is for the keyword bread recipes so if I
go to Google and just type in bread
recipes I'm going to be able to see
771 billion results for the keyword
bread recipes now is 771 billion are
real competition maybe maybe not what we
want to do is put in a syntax and we
want to put in the syntax all in title
and then colon space and then our
keyword and the reason why we do that in
search is because we want to be able to
identify the true competitive number or
the true number of websites who are
trying to rank for bread recipes and if
if we put in the syntax all en tile
colon and then our keyword bread recipes
we'll be able to see that there are 9
98,000 results that's a lot lower than
771 billion so that means that
98,000 sites or listings have the
keyword bread recipes in the title tag
and the title tag is what shows up in
the search engine results and so if I
look down and scroll down here I can see
bread recipes on in every one of these
title tags so title tag is an important
element to rank number one on Google and
we'll talk about that in a few minutes
but if we understand that there 998,199
our website to rank number one on Google
and so therefore I'm going to put in
$998,000 in my spreadsheet as the
competitive number and so now I could
see for the keyword bread recipes I have
60,500 and if my competition is $998,000
then my Kei or keyword Effectiveness
index or in other words the ratio of
volume to competition is 6% so that's
nothing more than volume divided by
competition so that tells me that my Kei
or my ratio between volume competition
is 6% so remember we want more volume
than we want competition so anytime you
do a keyword research you're going to
find a number of different relevant
keywords so if I go back into Google's
Keyword Planner if I typed in bread
recipes you could see that Google is
going to give me a number of different
keywords related to bread recipes let's
just say I have another keyword that I
want to think about optimizing for being
ranked on Google for and that's banana
bread recipe very similar keyword as
bread recipes except it's a little
longer tail now if I type in banana
bread recipe in Google's Keyword Planner
now I can see the average monthly search
volume is actually gone up it's
368,000 I can also see the competition
is low so those are good signs so now I
can see 368,000 I'm going to go ahead
and put that in my spreadsheet now I'm
going to go into Google I'm going to put
in my syntax all in title I'm going to
put in banana bread recipe I'm going to
hit enter and now I can see I have
233,000 results with the keyword banana
bread recipe in the title tag so if I
look at the title tags I can see banana
bread recipe banana bread recipe banana
bread recipe on all the listings in the
Google search results so that tells me I
have 233,000 results that I have to jump
over in order to rank number one on
Google so I'm going to put 233,000 in my
spreadsheet now I can see my Kei or my
volume to competition ratio is 157
158% and so to me that's a lot better
number to work with or in other words
that's a lot better keyword because it's
just as relevant and it has a higher
ratio of volume to competition so
therefore banana bread recipe is going
to be a better keyword to optimize for
in order to rank number one on Google so
that's the whole idea behind keyword
research you want to brainstorm ideas
there are plenty of tools out there so
the tool I recommend is Google ads
Keyword Planner Google's going to give
you how much search volume they're going
to tell you the competition but then
you're going to go into Google search
you're going to use the syntax all and
title to get a more accurate read on the
actual competitive number and so to find
out how keywords that your competitors
are ranking for you can use those
keyword tools that I mentioned another
tool that I use is MZ so MZ if you go to
ms.com they have a tool called keyword
Explorer so if we just type in the
keyword for example bread recipes it's
going to be able to tell us how much
volume and the difficulty so you can use
other tools at your disposal figure out
the volume and the difficulty there are
plenty of tools out there but the one
thing I would just make sure is you use
everything at your disposal so you can
use social media to find the most shared
article for particular topic or keyword
like bread recipes you could check other
platforms that have a a lot of shared
content like readin and Kora where you
can ask people about certain topics
using keywords to figure out how much
competition or volume there might be you
could stay up to date on industry news
to get an idea of what types of keywords
are trending but when it comes to
keywords and keyword research remember
for every web page we want to be able to
pick two keywords we want a primary and
secondary keyword so when we do keyword
research and we enter all our keywords
into our spreadsheet we want to be able
to have a number of different keywords
in this case we're focusing on the theme
bread recipes we want to have different
keywords because we want to be able to
choose a primary keyword and a secondary
keyword because we want to be able to
focus on multiple keywords for each page
because we don't want to put necessarily
all our eggs in one basket maybe we
won't want to put all our emphasis just
on one keyword to rank for we want
multiple keywords to try and rank four
so the primary keyword can to find the
nature of our business the secondary
keyword can be just highly relevant to
our keyword at the end of the day we
want to choose multiple keywords to try
and rank on Google for that page so for
example we have a Blog and we're using
ice cream recipes and we're blogging
about ice cream recipes we can have a
primary keyword that is about ice cream
recipes or homemade ice cream recipes
we're going to always want to find out
what the volume in the competition is
our secondary keyword could be built
around other similar keywords like
lowfat ice cream recipes or fat-free ice
cream recipes or low-fat homemade ice
cream recipes those are complimentary
keywords just like our bread recipes and
banana bread recipe so one thing we want
to do when we do keyword research is we
want to be be able to Target one keyword
per content when you can Target many we
want to be able to Target multiple
keywords not necessarily Target one
keyword and so we want to be able to
Cluster keywords so we don't want to
Target just one we want to Target
multiple keywords per page and when we
talk about clustering if we go back to
our keyword research what we're doing is
we're clustering a bunch of keywords
under the theme bread recipes and so by
looking at the volume looking at the
competition looking at the Kei we can
choose different keywords for our page
and that's what we mean by clustering we
want to Cluster keywords into a Content
theme so why Target only one keyword per
content when we can Target many because
we don't want to put all our eggs in one
basket we don't want to Target just one
keyword we want to Target many and so
that means clustering your keywords into
a theme and choosing multiple keywords
for that particular particular page and
when we do that we have a better
opportunity to rank high on Google
Search and the whole idea behind ranking
high on Google Search is we can get the
volume so if we know we're ranked number
one on Google search for bread recipes
or banana bread recipe we know we stand
a chance of getting a majority of the
volume associated with that keyword and
if we can get the volume and get the
traffic then we can get the conversions
so let's move on to high quality content
and talk about the impact content has on
your ability to get your website ranked
number one on Google so let's just say
you have content on your website and the
content is ranking on you know page four
of Google and it's that blog with ice
cream recipes and if it's just content
for the sake of content is not really
informative then then it's not
necessarily going to get good engagement
in the eyes of Google you know they want
to rank content that's very informative
it's very fresh it's exciting to read
it's interesting it's going to have good
engagement so if it's a recipe or an
article about any topic if it's the
content is just not informative then
you're not going to get good engagement
and when you don't get good engagement
if people don't stay on the site to
engage in the content and they just
leave the website after landing on the
page causing a bounce then the content
is just going to continue to fall down
the rankings and we want to prevent that
we want to move up the rankings we want
to be number one on Google we don't
necessarily want to fall in the rankings
for our content so content is a key
driver in being able to rank number one
on Google so if the content is on page n
what can we do well we want to be able
to you know take that content and do
something with it we feel like we did WR
engaging content so let's go ahead and
share it on social media and to me
social media is a good platform to share
your content because on social media
platforms like Facebook for example
you're building a community on that
platform that Community is already
interested in your content so if you're
sharing an ice cream recipe especially
in the summertime and you're engaging
with your community on that platform
then the likelihood of that community on
that platform is going to increase
engagement increased engagement will
send social signals to the search engine
it says hey this content is good quality
likewise for any other platform most
social media platforms have engagement
metrics and those engagement metrics
pass signals is it good is it not good
do we like this content are we giving it
a thumbs up are we going to want to
follow it are we going to want to share
it and so if you share content that you
feels engaging on social platforms then
it's going to be engaging and it's
likely going to cause an increase in
engagement for example a decrease in
balances and once you share that quality
content then the likelihood of it moving
up the rankings even as far as number
one on Google is going to be greater so
you always want to start out writing
good quality content so let's talk about
good quality content because Google does
take content seriously they do take into
account what other people think of that
content so high quality content is an
important factor so how to create good
content that's always the question so
let's talk about some best practices
here remember in the last segment we
talked about keyword research so we want
to perform good keyword research why
because we want to choose keywords
remember we're choosing multiple
keywords per page one keyword could be
related to our brand one keyword could
be related to the content but another
keyword could be related to a user's
intent like recipes if you recall the
example we use with bread recipes maybe
somebody's looking to type in a keyword
that says how do I make you know a bread
or how do I make a specific type of
bread or how do I make banana bread or
what's the best recipe for banana bread
they're question related and we want to
be able to answer those questions so
that's where choosing those right
keywords that's going to respond to a
user's intent so starts with choosing
the right keywords so remember we talked
about a number of different tools when
we talked about keyword research so
there's a research tool that you can use
called phrase. iio and that will help
you do quick research on you know
keywords and Trends and whatnot so if
you know about a research tool that you
use for keyword research then drop us a
comment below I be interested in getting
your comments about keyword research and
what research tools are out there so if
you know something better than phrase.
drop a comment below and we'd be
interested in getting your perspective
so keyword research is key but creating
content that fulfills users requirements
so answering those questions if it's a
recipe we want to answer that question
if it's directions we want to answer
that question if they don't know how to
do something we want to answer that
question and that's the whole idea
behind content content is not just to
fill a page it's to really fulfill users
requirements that's when you get good
engagement so if somebody's typing in
something on Google and they're looking
for an answer your content should answer
that question but we also want to make
the content readable so in other words
you know write for your audience don't
impress anybody with very high
vocabulary type words that somebody
doesn't necessarily know the meaning of
don't use jargon don't use a street
language for example use everyday common
language that's just easily digestible
when your audience is reading and then
we want to keep that content organized
and so when we mean organized we want to
use headers and subheaders you know
break your content into paragraphs keep
the flow organized if we can keep the
flow organized then it's going to be
easier for somebody to read and then
it's okay to add resources especially
resources from credible sites so if you
can incorporate those resources in there
then it's just going to add The
credibility to your content let the
audience know that hey I've done my
research on this topic and this is what
this person has to say about it this
person who seems to be credible okay so
it only adds value to your content so
these are all tips to Remember When
creating content and then the one
important tip here is we want to use
white hat techniques and when we say
white hat techniques that means you know
if we've chosen keywords that are going
to answer somebody's question we don't
want to stuff those keywords into the
content we want the content to be
naturally written so when we say op for
white heck uh techniques that's what we
mean write the content naturally keep it
organized keep it readable include third
party sources and make sure it answers a
question so there are different types of
content so there's content where you
just write words it's all text based you
could also use an infograph and
infograph is simply just a graphic that
visualizes exactly what you're trying to
explain for example if we want to write
an article about how to write good
engaging content we don't necessarily
have to write all that out as a text we
can create an infographic so for example
here's an infographic on 20 effective
ways to basically not bore your readers
but write engaging content so you could
see this is an infographic it's all
graphically laid out so infographics
tend to be easier to understand because
they're visual they're easy for the end
user to comprehend because there's
generally no jargon it's usually images
that are portraying the points of what
you're trying to get across and so it
tends to break it up the monotony of
just text it's more visually appealing
and it's laid out and organized so you
can see this infographic has 20
different steps rules and they lay those
out all here in this infographic and the
great thing I like about infographics is
you could you could share them on social
media you can re-engage them as a post
you could save them on really any social
platform so infographics tend to tell a
better
story versus say just writing text you
can use video and images so you don't
necessarily have to lay it all out in an
infographic you can certainly insert a
video or an image into
your content especially if it's a blog
post if it's a blog post then sometimes
video and images on its own tell the
story you don't necessarily need text to
go ahead and tell your story a video or
an image as they say tells a thousand
words and so images and videos are great
to use in a blog post so using different
forms of content you know you always
want to review your content when a user
dwells on your web page for a longer
time Google will tend to think okay this
person's engaged so we're going to rank
that favorably so if you're using
infographics videos and images then the
chances of somebody being more engaged
are going to increase versus just text
that's not well organized and written
out in a way that somebody doesn't
necessarily understand so be creative in
the types of content you use so longer
engaging cont content tends to bode well
with search engines so this is according
to HubSpot so the more word count you
use the more words you use the chances
of you ranking higher are going to be
better just take into account best
practices you want to maybe break up the
content with an image organize it make
it engaging use headers so it's not
necessarily just words it's the words
and how those words are written how
they're structured the types key words
you're using how you're engaging with
your audience there's a lot of factors
again there best practices we just went
over but the key is you know if you have
longer more engaging content then it's
going to bode better for you on search
engines so couple of steps to create
highquality content so you want to begin
with a comprehensive introduction so
always introduce your content remember
the content should be relevant to the
keyword so if you're choosing keywords
and your keyword research think about
answering that question if somebody's
typing in bread recipes maybe they're
looking for banana bread recipes how to
make the best banana bread or how to
make banana bread using dried figs we
want to be able to align our content
with that keyword naturally you want to
create a title that's worthy that's
click worthy so remember if you're in
Google search and you're doing search
for something simple like bread recipe
Rees we want to some make something
that's going to be you know engaging for
somebody to click on like easy perfect
yeast bread or easy crusty French bread
or something that's going to be engaging
you know the best bread recipes or how
to make the best homemade bread you know
something that's going to draw
somebody's attention to the title of
that blog post so we want to include LSI
keywords so what I mean by LSI keywords
in your content we mean you know
longtail keywords make it natural
headings and subheadings should consist
of keywords and variant so if you're
writing headers and subheaders include
the keyword in there and that way the
the content always stays relevant to the
audience okay shorten your sentences and
paragraphs so don't write long
paragraphs remember we want to break
this up we want to make it easy for the
end user to read and we want to always
put internal links on our blog post why
because if we have internal links then
if we have a link from one blog post to
another blog post or say our blog post
to an internal page on our website we
want to make sure that it's relevant
content that way if somebody's reading
something and you have an internal link
let's just say from a bread recipes page
to a banana bread recipes page then they
may find it interesting click on that
link and go to the banana bread recipes
page so it's keeping somebody engaged on
your webs it so putting in internal
linking will help keep the the end user
engaged because you're offering up links
that's relevant to the content you
always want to break up that content
with images okay we want to use alt tags
meaning we want to pen the image with
text so that way if the image doesn't
load then at least the alt text will
load so we can incorporate call out
boxes and more importantly we we want to
update our content regularly so we
always want to get the best recipe out
there if it's banana bread or different
ways to create b in a bread or always
just coming up with ways to update the
content so we want to keep our content
our blog post fresh and then we want to
include a CTA call to action if we
include a call to action then that's
going to keep somebody engaged and have
them act on your content so these are
steps to creating highquality content
content and so let's look at an example
here and this is a 3month Old Post on
BuzzFeed and it's 21 pictures that
restore your faith in humanity so it has
a lot of likes a lot of tweets and that
means it's engaged people are engaged
when reading that and so if we go and
look at it as an example we can see it
in on BuzzFeed here 21 pictures that
will restore your faith in humanity so
this was written back in 2012 again a
lot of engagement but if we look at it
we can see immediately that it's taking
into account third party sources it's
got some content it's got images it's
being broken up by images we could see
there's call to actions on there in the
form of social so people can go ahead
and go ahead and share it if they like
it okay it includes videos it includes
images third party sources so it's a
good post because listen you know it's
engaging content it's probably answering
somebody's question about humanity and
we can see clearly that look you know
there's a lot of different examples here
from a lot of different sources and we
could take action on this content so not
just video not just images but text as
well and so it's very engaging answers
questions takes into account the
different types of content available so
this is a good post in that regard so
content's updated regularly it's
engaging and it includ includes sources
from high Authority websites some dos
and don'ts on the content so take into
account the best practices I mentioned
about creating high quality content okay
answer those questions that the end user
wants to hear you know CU that likely is
going to be their search and so you want
to be able to respond to the end user
that's part of creating high quality
content different types of content I.E
in the form of infographics or videos or
text or images you can add images from
public domain sites you can be relatable
and use examples to clarify points just
like the BuzzFeed article simplify
complex words don't use sophisticated
language talk to your audience as if you
they were standing right in front of you
and use bullet points to exemplify your
examples your points so some dos the
don'ts obviously don't lift content we
don't want to lift content from another
website so that's plagiarism so we want
to have our own unique content we also
don't want to take images from other
websites and so if you do happen to find
an image that works for your post and
it's on somebody else's website ideally
that's not a good situation but if you
do happen to do that then always give
credit to the website okay so if you
took it from xyz.com credit xyz.com for
the image and even put a link back but
ideally you don't want want to take
images from other websites just as much
as you don't want to take copy you don't
want to take images use your own imagery
and content but if you don't have
imagery then you can always go to stock
photography there are plenty of websites
out there where you can sign up for a
subscription like uh Adobe stock images
as an example you can sign up for an
account and in some cases you can sign
up for a free account and use stock
imagery okay don't give less information
to your audience give your audience what
they deserve which is the information
they're looking for they're looking for
the best banana bread recipes give them
the best banana bread recipes
incorporate your own images break it up
with titles give them a good quality
piece of content that they're going to
be able to engage with and so if you put
long paragraphs in your content then
it's going to be less engaging so try to
avoid those long paragraphs remember
shorten up the paragraph keep the
language simple add in images answer
those questions use third party credible
sources but write it in your own words
and you should be on your way to
creating good quality content okay so
now that we've talked about high quality
content in order to get your pages
ranked high on Google search let's turn
our attention to optimizing onpage
elements and discuss some website level
factors that are both going to help you
rank high on Google search so let's just
do an overview of what we're talking
about when we talk about onpage elements
and website level factors so optimizing
on page elements include a number of
different things but primarily we're
going to focus in on meta tags also
known as meta description tags header
tags also known as title tags and URLs
so those are just some of the on page
elements we want to be able to optimize
using relevant keywords in order to rank
high on Google search we also want to
take a look at some website factors that
will affect our ranking on Google search
they include website architecture having
a secure website having a s map and
taking a look at page speed so all of
those are some of the website factors we
need to take into account in order to
rank high on Google search so title tag
and meta description
together are considered metat tags so
both play an important role in ranking
high on Google so we want to be able to
write unique title and descriptions for
each page on our website when I say
unique that means a title and The Meta
description need to be different for
every page on the website and so if
you're not quite sure what a title tag
and a meta description tag is if you go
to search and just type in any
particular search query the title tag is
what's going to show up here in bold and
then the description is going to show up
below it below the URL and that's going
to describe the page so both of these
meta tags are important because it
describes what your page is all about
and that's what Google uses in the
search results pages so we want to be
able to pay attention to the length of
our metat tags so if we go back to our
search results Pages met title tags are
generally 60 65 characters metad
description tags are generally 160
characters so anything really longer
than that then what's going to happen is
the meta description tag or the title
tag will get truncated and so if we look
here for example we can see all of the
title tags here fit the 65 character
limit but if you run over the character
count on meta description then Google is
going to trunk at the copy so you want
to stay within your parameters in order
to avoid getting your content truncated
and so the other thing when we're
writing title meta description tags we
want to minimize keyword repetition so
if we're optimizing for keyword we don't
want to necessarily just plug that
keyword into the title tag and meta
description multiple times we want to
make sure our title tags and meta
descriptions are naturally written so if
somebody's typing for banana bread
recipe with dried fig you know we want
to have a nice title tag and a this
description that is going to get
somebody to respond uh based on their
need and so we definitely want to avoid
keyword repetition but we want to be
able to use that keyword in the title
tag because if you remember from the
earlier segment when we did the all in
title syntax to find out exactly how
many competitors were using that
particular keyword well we obviously
want to use that keyword in the title
tag because again the title tag is an
important factor when it comes to search
engine results so we want to use the
keyword but we want to avoid stuffing or
using it repetitively in our title tag
and our meta description we want the
title tag in The Meta description to
describe the page sound natural but also
be engaging because the point is we want
people to click on our link and go to
our website from search engines so title
tags with number
tend to result in higher click the rates
this is according to Ms so for example
if you just put in a title tag that says
learn digital marketing well that may
work but if you put a number in there
like five easy ways to learn digital
marketing that might get somebody to
click on your link and go to your
website so having questions in your
metat taxs can also increase your click
theate for example if you just put learn
the importance of first page rankings
not too bad but they again generic but
if you put it into the formal question
how to rank number one on Google it's
more action oriented it's going to get
somebody to resonate with the question
that they have and that may be their
query how to rank number one on Google
and so these techniques will help you
get higher clicky rates and so according
to back Linko title tag with a keyword
can improve site ranking so remember we
want to include that keyword the title
tag even though we only have 65
characters we want to include that
keyword but we want to avoid stuffing
the keyword in there we want to again
make the title tag action oriented maybe
with a number maybe as a question with
the keyword in there once naturally not
easy to do but that's the beauty of SEO
if you can follow these best practices
and write a good title tag then the
chances of you improving in your search
results are going to be greater so
having only one H1 tag in your post is
going to be good so remember when
somebody clicks on a link so let's say
they do find a title tag engaging and
they click on this this link here and
they go to that website you know you
want to start out with having that
particular H1 Tech because the H1 teag
especially with a keyword in it is going
to signal to Google hey we're organizing
page and because it's an H1 tag it's
important we're structuring the page
according to best practices so having
only one H1 tag in your post is
definitely helpful having multiple tags
H tags in your post help organize the
page a lot better so we want to add that
targeted keyword in that tag and your
header tag should be relevant to the
content so if we go back to our example
of the using dried figs with banana
breads well the title says California
fig banana bread and remember the last
segment when we're talking about high
quality content we'll look no further
than including a video into our content
so not only will this video help keep
the engagement high but it breaks up the
monotony of the page and it's from a
third party source so it adds
credibility to the page so adding a
videos based on the last segment of high
quality content definitely helps with
ranking high on Google search so
following hierarchal structure that
means putting those H tags in there H2
tags help break up the content and we
want to avoid repetition of H1 tags on
your different web pages of your site
meaning don't just put the same H1 tag
with the same keyword in it and keeping
it Blas we want to make those H1 tags
exciting to read but also used
appropriately to break up the content so
remember all white hat techniques
we want to avoid hidden text we want to
avoid stuffing keywords we want things
to be natural we don't want things to be
forced and your H1 tag should be 20 to
70 characters don't make long H1 tags so
if we go back to our page example a
short sweet tag here California fig
banana bread it's relevant to the
content it's short sweet it breaks up
the monotony of the content and more
importantly again any content you have
on the page should always answer the
users's intent remember people are using
search to answer questions find
information our content should be able
to answer that for them so according to
John Moher senior webmas Trends Analyst
at Google header tags would definitely
help Google for rankings and the search
results so we want to use header tags so
when it comes to URLs we want to use
hyphens and avoid underscores so if we
look at the this URL here this uses
hyphens fig and banana bread so it's all
broken up with hyphens that's the best
practice remember canonical URLs a
canonical URL signals to Google this is
the original content so we want to use
original content and if you have
multiple sources of content out there on
say different websites we want to use a
canonical tag to signal to Google this
is the original content please Index
this content and not doesn't hurt to use
a favicon in url meaning a small icon it
helps to break up the monotony and help
your URL stand out we can add targeted
keywords in the URL so again looking at
the URL here I can see we're using
targeted keyword as part of the URL
structure fig and banana bread and
notice the H1 tag is fig banana bread so
it's all consistent and it flows
naturally URLs that are no longer exist
existing then we want to be able to set
up a redirect for those URLs meaning a
301 redirect is a server response for
Google that says Hey Google this page is
no longer available but we permanently
redirected it to this page which is now
available so that's what a 301 redirect
does it helps signal to Google and all
the other search engines that if the
page is no longer there that's fine
you're just going to go to this page
this is the page that's permanently
there now and another thing we want do
here is if you have mobile URLs you want
to include those in the sitemap and
we're going to hit on that in just a
minute but all urls should be mobile
friendly as well as desktop friendly
meaning take into account this best
practices keep your url short use
hyphens put the keyword in that URL and
make it easy to understand want to avoid
capital letters in the URLs the URLs are
case sensitive so go lowercase you
should should always go lowercase on the
URL readable URLs again the rule of
thumb here is if you understand what the
URL is then Google's going to understand
what the URL is so the shorter the URL
the easier it is to read the easier it
is to read the better chance you have to
rank high on Google search so according
to backlink to URLs that are shorter
definitely definitely help you rank so
we want to be able to shorten those URLs
keep them short and sweet
don't make them long and unreadable so
those are some on optimized ways or on
page elements that help you optimize now
we want to look at some website level
factors that will help you optimize and
rank high on Google search so good site
structure provides better crawling for
search engine Bots and what do we mean
by that well we mean having your site
organized in a fashion that Google's
going to be able to find all the pages
so what do we mean by that create a
logical hierarchy structure so if you're
selling shoes you know you're going to
have a homepage break the structure up
into men's shoes women's shoes
Children's Shoes then under men's shoes
you could have it by brand it could be
Nike Puma Adidas on the women's side it
could be Nike Puma Adidas on the child
side it could be Nike Puma Adidas and so
you want to keep the structure flow in a
hierarchy so we want to balance the
amount of subcategories within each
category so the men's if it has Nike
Puma Adidas the women should have Nike
Puma Adidas and so you want to code your
site navigation and CSS or HTML meaning
we want to be able to use something that
Google is going to be able to index so
most sites are built in HTML and that's
what Google likes to index they like to
index something that they could take
back to their servers and then more
importantly build a comprehensive
structure for internal linking so
internal links mean that if you're on a
site you should have natural links
pointing to other pages on your website
so to keep the flow going and we don't
want to have unnatural inbound links you
always want to have natural internal
links to keep the flow of the user going
from one page to the other so here I
could see as an example all the
ingredients in this recipe well this has
an internal link to another page on our
site and this happens to link to page
where somebody can buy the ingredient so
it's a natural internal link so John DH
of Credo has claimed that one of the
biggest changes that he can make in
fixing the crto website is architecture
so for example in Credo John dhy has
increased the organic sessions by 74% in
Pages by procession by 41% just by
changing the site architecture so you'd
be surprised by changing the site
architecture what that will do to
engagement and so let's turn our
attention to secure versus non-secure so
what we mean by that is securing your
site we want to make it sure that
compliant with certain protocols and so
if we go back here we can see that this
particular site is compliant it is
secure https means it has a secure
license meaning the site is secure so
Google likes secure versus non-secure so
non-secure would be HTTP so we want
https as our protocol and what that
means is just and enabling SSL
certificates and that means when you
enable an SSL certificate that means
your domain or your protocol is going to
be turned to https so Google prefers
sites that are secure versus non-secure
so if you use
hsts as a protocol that adds an extra
layer of security over the https and
hsts prevents cookie hijacking so adding
multiple layers of security always helps
in my opinion if you have an HTTP
website a non-secure website you should
look into buying an SSL certificate
getting your sites flipped over to
https because what's going to happen is
your url structure is going to change
when your url structure changes Google's
going to recognize that because they're
going to index your site and when they
index your site they're going to see
those secure URLs and that's going to
work favorably in your fa
and help you rank higher on Google
search so websites using secure or
https have a higher chance of ranking
higher so https is a ranking signal
because Google indexes those pages so
let's also talk about sit Maps so
sitemap is one of the most important
ways to improve your website ranking why
well because sitemaps are a way to
organize all your URLs into one file so
we're basically going to a priority
prioritize all our web pages in a Sit
map so if you go to any particular
website and you type in sitemap XML
you're likely going to see all the pages
on your website so usually the site map
is located in the root directory so if I
type in sitemap.xml I'm going to be able
to see all the pages in my root
directory and I can also prioritize them
I can also alert Google as to how often
they change and every every page is
going to have a date stamp associated
with it so Google can actually see how
often it changes so remember we want our
content to be updated frequently so if
content is not updated frequently or
it's not fresh then Google's going to
see that s that date stamp that last
modification D so we want to be able to
make sure our content's updated
frequently we want to let Google know
that we changed it frequently and we
want to be able to prioritize our Pages
let Google know hey these pages are
important to to us so all that can be
set up in a sitemap we want to be able
to add canonical versions of URLs in the
sitemap so we want to be able to add all
our original URLs in our sitemap and so
we always want to build Dynamic URLs sit
maps for larger websites and what do I
mean by Dynamic URLs that means that if
I look at this s map and we're always
adding content let's just say in the
form of a Blog well guess what we want
those pages to be added to the sitemap
as they're published so as we add pages
to the blog or to the site then they
should automatically be added to the
site map and so in effect what's going
to happen is we're going to be able to
see the sitemap grow with more URLs when
the sitemap grows with more URLs then
that means then Google's going to index
more pages they're going to index more
fresh pages so they're going to be able
to get those pages that are just
published quicker so that's the whole
idea behind dynamic sit Maps is we want
to be able to capture all the URLs just
as they're published and we want to be
able to maintain our site maps and so I
would always recommend a dynamic sit map
but you can always create your own sit
map just by going to a tool called XML
sitemap so if I just type in XML
sitemaps into Google search here I can
see XML sitemaps generator and I can be
able if I have a small website just
create a free and simple sit map on my
own when XML sitemaps creates it or your
platform creates a dynamic sit map
either way the site map's going to sit
in the root directory and then what we
want to do in turn is let Google know
where that sitemap is so in search
console we want to be able to submit the
sitemap so you're going to add the
sitemap you're going to let Google know
where it is it should be in the root
directory and it should be called
sitemap.xml and when you do that
Google's going to be able to take those
URLs and index them so we could see we
submitted 528 URLs Google index 521 so
one thing about URLs here is when we
create a site map we're putting all your
URLs in there we do not add no index
URLs in your sitemap and what that means
is that any URL we don't want Google to
index we're just going to exclude from
the sitemap okay so we want Google to
take all the URLs we want indexed and
put them in the sitemap so according to
edgy using sit maps for SEO can increase
your websites visibility and help you
get indexed why because what you're in
fact doing is taking all your URLs that
you want index you're telling Google how
often they're modified you're telling
Google which ones are important and
you're submitting that to Google and so
Google's going to be able to take all
these URLs quicker index them quicker
and when they're index quicker you can
get rank quicker and when you get ranked
quicker you can get traffic quicker so
that's the whole idea behind sit Maps so
let's turn our attention to page speed
now so one of the last factors for our
website besides architecture making it
secure and adding site Maps is you want
to take a look at how quick our Pages
load here are some tips in order to
optimize page speed because ideally the
quicker a page loads the more engaged
the user is going to be if it takes a
longer time for the page to load all the
elements of that page then what's going
to happen is the user is going to get
impatient maybe leave the website all
together or go to another page and so we
want to be able to optimize images so
any image that's of large size in terms
of megabytes we want to be able to
optimize that compress the image so
that's one way to speed up page speed we
want to use a simple website design you
know HTML with CSS or cascading
stylesheet just a simple design with
simple hierarchy and website navigation
structure so nothing fancy nothing
complex just a simple website design
with optimized images we want to
leverage browser cach in and we want to
upgrade the server response time meaning
all your files are sitting on the server
so when somebody goes to a web page the
server is serving up all of those files
the images the text Etc and so we want
the server to respond on as quick as
possible so when it comes to page speed
we can look at the factors affecting
page speed in Google analytics so if I
go to Google analytics and I go under
behavior and I go under sight speed and
I go to overview I'm going to be able to
see what my average load time is for my
site and ideally we want our pages to
load as quick as possible so that means
anything under 4 seconds anything 4
seconds or higher and it's like likely
the end user is going to leave the page
there's a correlation be between page
load time and bounce rate and so what
Google actually does is give you speed
suggestions so if we do have a page that
loads slow we can just go to speed
suggestions in Google analytics and we
go to speed suggestions then Google's
going to be able to tell us hey this
particular page load fast this
particular page loads slow and if it
loaded slow why is it loading slow so
here we can see the homepage as example
is loaded on average of 7 Seconds well
if we look here they're going to give us
some suggestions so if I click on this
page speed suggestions it's going to
load a report and a tool called page
speed insights and basically what it's
then going to do after it's done running
is this going to tell me all the ways in
which I can optimize my pages not only
for desktop but also for mobile so here
I can see for desktop or for mobile I
can look at some ways in which I can
optimize it to increase page speed for
example sizing my images properly server
response time reducing my server
response time avoiding multiple page
redirects so there's a lot of
opportunities that we can do to speed up
page loow time and all that's found in
page speed insights and all that's found
within Google analytics so remember
optimizing code minimizing redirects
optimizing your images
upgrading your server respon all of
those are factors and so again you can
go into analytics page speed insights
and you could see exactly what Google is
recognizing as what's lowering or
slowing down your page load time so
Google takes site speed as one of the
most important ranking factors why
because they're going to rank Pages not
only with high quality content that are
relevant to the keyword queries but they
want those pages to have a good user
experience so if somebody clicks on the
page then the user should be able to see
that content fairly quickly and so
that's why it's such an important factor
so the quicker your pages load the
chances of you ranking higher are going
to be better so according to web
performance today Walmart as an example
experienced a decline in conversions so
what they did was looked at their page
speed and when they looked at their page
speed you'd be surprised what that did
just increasing it from 1 to 4 seconds
or decreasing it basically increase
conversion so there's always going to be
a correlation between how quick a page
loads and how engaged the user is
because if it's users engaged they're
going to stay on the site and if they
stay on the site then their chances of
converting are going to be higher so
just even one to two seconds increase in
page loow low time will make a world of
difference in terms of Engagement and
conversions let's turn our attention to
offsite engagement so previously we
talked about on on page elements and
website factors that affect our rankings
for search results but we also need to
turn our attention away from our website
meaning what we do on our website and
turn our attention what we can do for
our website off our website and on to
other websites so that's offsite
engagement and so let's look at an
example so that ice cream recipes blog
so we did everything we possibly could
we updated The Meta tags the title tag
The Meta description we added H1 tags we
made sure the site architecture was
sound we submitted a site map we we made
sure the page load was good and fast so
we did all the things we were supposed
to do on our web page but we're still
not ranking well what do we need to do
well we need to turn our attention away
from our website into other websites we
call this off site or off page SEO and
we need to basically generate links from
high quality sites back to our site so
if we've done everything we can on our
own website and we're still not ranking
where we want to be well then we need to
turn our attention to other websites and
so if we turn our attention to other
websites and other websites that are
relevant other websites that are of
quality other websites that have high
domain Authority then we're going to see
an increase in rankings so it's just a
matter of getting
quality links from quality websites that
are relevant that's what's going to move
the needle on search after we've taken
care of all the onpage elements so more
backlinks from high domain Authority
results in higher rankings SEO is a
combination between what we do on our
website meaning optimizing the page and
making sure our website has good site
architecture and follows the best
practices in terms of site maps and page
load then we need to turn our attention
to the backlinking to improve our domain
Authority so according to backlinko
analysis offsite engagement is one of
the most important elements for ranking
number one in Google so you can't just
focus your attention on updating the
title tag and making sure the pages load
fast you have to turn your attention as
well to getting back links from high
quality sites that's offsite engagement
and so gaining links back links from
multiple DS is vital it's vital because
they bring referring traffic to your
site they bring credibility to your site
but more importantly Google's going to
recognize the relationship between these
sites and your website and if these
sites that have back links or links
pointing to your site and if they're of
high quality then we call that passing
linkes so it's going to bring quality to
you in terms of organic search so if we
look at an example if I do a search for
banana bread recipe there're
241 billion results for banana bread
recipe Why did this particular page from
Simply Recipes rank number one well we
can turn our attention to MZ and MZ has
a report called link Explorer and so MZ
link explor report helps us identify our
own page Authority our own domain
Authority and how many links we have
from other quality websites so if I put
that particular URL into link Explorer
and notice the URL here is short even
though it uses an underscore when it
should use a hyphen it's still ranked
number one and why because off page
elements help this page rank number one
why their page Authority out of 100 is
58 their domain Authority out of 100 is
8 2 and what does that mean well that
means that they have a lot of good links
from other domains of high quality they
have 824 linking domains to this one
domain they have 3600 inbound links and
they're ranking for a lot of different
keywords so if we scroll down we're
going to be able to see kind of a
breakout the quality of websites that
are linking to them so they have 19
domains with a domain authority of 91 to
100 linking to them they have 15 domains
between the range of 81 and 90 so what
does that tell me between 15 and 19
that's 34 particular domains that are
very high quality linking to them and so
we could see the breakout of the linking
domains we could see the top file links
to the site and we could see the page
Authority so the link explor report
gives us an overview of what pages are
linking to ours and it also G gives us
an idea of what our own page Authority
and domain Authority are because domain
Authority and Page Authority both need
to be high in order for us to rank on
Google Search and in order for it to get
high we need links from high quality
sites so that's the whole idea behind
offside engagement so some of the
offside engagements are influencer
marketing meaning is there's somebody
out there on social who has a huge
following but not only do they have a
huge following but are they
relevant to our product for example usin
B who's a famous Sprinter if we're
selling shoes and we're selling Nike
shoes maybe husin Bol can reference us
on Twitter or Facebook that's influencer
marketing getting people to influencing
people to buy our product we can engage
with audiences on multiple social media
platforms like Facebook and Twitter
meaning if we're running a promotion on
those running shoes then we can promote
that on Facebook okay we can promote
that on Twitter we can also bookmark our
web page on popular bookmarking sites
like stumble upon we can also put our
content on discussion forums like Reddit
we can join High PR quality Q&A sites
excuse me and post answers to questions
related to our business like kora.com so
we can engage in sharing our content and
answering questions so there's lots of
ways to get get links to your website if
you have a blog post as an example you
can make sure that maybe that content is
shared on a similar blog post so you
have an ice cream recipe blog post well
maybe you can look at a dessert blog
post and share your content on that
particular blog post and have a backlink
pointing from that blog post to yours as
an example and you can reciprocate so
the whole idea of content is sharing in
the content but at the same time of
sharing it you're producing backlinks
and backlinks help domain Authority so
not only do they help domain Authority
but they improve the search ranking so
in Google's eyes the higher your domain
Authority hire the page Authority in
Google's eyes that means your page is
important it's credible and we're going
to improve it in the search engine
rankings it increases brand visibility
if we have our content on a highly
engageable website a highly popular
website or blog it's not it's going to
lift our brand visibility if we have
usin B who's very famous Sprinter do
some influenc in marketing for us then
that's going to increase our brand
visibility so anytime we can associate
with something that has some influence
or some clout or high domain Authority
then it's only going to increase our
brand awareness and visibility so again
it's going to increase our domain
Authority because of the association of
passing link juice from one domain to
another it's going to then as a result
increase referral traffic because if
we're on a high quality website that
gets a lot of traffic then the chances
of some of that traffic going our site's
going to be great and again it improves
The credibility and Trust of our website
and that's what we want we want Google
to trust us and a way to build trust is
by associating our website with other
websites of high equal or higher quality
so when we talk about offside engagement
we want to do some guest post on
relevant websites so if you have that
ice cream blog go to another blog like
the the dessert blog and do a guest post
so not only that will that improve your
brand awareness but it'll generate a
backlink and maybe drive some referral
traffic you can participate in forums
and blog discussions like core.com or
Reddit get your content out there start
a discussion about a specific topic to
engage users build brand awareness and
generate that backlink you can always
you know put your your site on a
directory like Yelp for example or Yahoo
directory you could prefer testimonial
link building meaning if you serve
products or offer up a service well
somebody could provide a testimony on
their website or you can just earn
backlinks from relevant authoritative
web pages like we mentioned Kora or
Wikipedia there's plenty out there so
the idea is to associate yourself with
high quality websites but do it
naturally you don't want to force
anything so if you're selling a specific
service or you're selling a specific
product look for like mining services or
products that complement what you do and
that'll create the natural environment
natural ecosystem that will eventually
give you the benefits that you need to
rank higher in the search results pages
so we don't want to purchase any links
we don't want to cloak content we don't
want to just inject links on sites that
aren't relevant we don't want to just
have sitewide links all over the place
pointing to the same page and we
certainly don't want to be on low
quality websites or directories it's all
about quality not quantity with offside
engagement so having offside engagement
complements what you do on your website
for on-site together both of those
efforts will get you higher search
engine results so if you are looking to
become an Su professional then look no
further than simply learn postgraduate
program in digital marketing find the
cost Link in description box for more
information is your website not ranking
as you thought it
would are there too many competitions
out
there is it getting difficult to capture
relevant
audiences are the solutions suggested
too expensive do not worry in this video
you will get easy solutions to all your
questions as we have come up with the
list of top 10 SEO tools that anyone can
use and the best part is you need not to
spend a single penny on these tools Yes
you heard it right they are free of cost
and are very useful for anyone who wants
to start an online business or
struggling to improve reach so let's
jump right into the list but before we
do kindly subscribe to our Channel
simply learn and hit the Bell icon to
never miss on such interesting and
useful videos to carry out best SE
practices the first free tool on our
list is the Keyword
Planner Keyword Planner is a free
keyword research tool provided by Google
proper keyword research is important as
it increases the possibility to rank
well on the search result Pages the
Keyword Planner will help to discover
new keywords estimate monthly searches a
keyword has get the cost of ads for the
keyword you're looking for and help to
organize keywords let's understand how
to use Google Keyword
Planner open your AdWords account now go
to the tools section and select Keyword
Planner now you can either add a keyword
to get new insights or upload a CSV file
to get search volumes of already known
keywords let's see how it
works click on discover new
keywords from here you can change the
location enter the keyphrase for which
you need keyword
insights
click on get
results here you can see all the keyword
ideas related to your keyword
phrase now to get the search volumes of
already known keywords go to the Keyword
Planner and click on get search volume
and
forecast now upload your CSV file from
here here you will get search volumes
for all the
keywords other similar tools with fre
trials include keywordtool.io
and keyword generator by
RFS to know trending ideas you can use
Google Trends whereas to get title ideas
you can use the answer the public tool
which is free now let's see the next
tool in the
bucket Google search console Google
search console is a free web master tool
provided by Google it is important to
timely monitor your website and make it
error free this is where Google search
console comes into the picture it helps
businesses to Monitor and maintain their
web we sites pres in Google search
results some features of Google Search
console
includes getting information that Google
search engine can crawl your website fix
the problems in page indexing sends
Pages for
reindexing can view Google search
traffic data records the number of times
you website appears in the search
results records the search queries for
which webs site appears in the search
result shows the list of sites linking
to you and many
more let's Now understand how to use
Google search
console here the total Impressions
suggest that number of times your
website appears in the Google search
results whereas the total clicks suggest
that number of times your website is
clicked from the Google search result
page
from the coverage section you will get
to know all the errors occurred during
The
Crawling we recommend you to try Your
Hands On Tools like Bing web master tool
and RFS which is free for website owners
next up we have the used SEO
plug-in used SEO plugin helps in
improving your search results ranking it
has a free as well as a paid version as
a beginner you can quickly check the
free
version it has an inbuilt feature that
automatically carries out SE analysis
and readability analysis and
automatically adds structured data let's
take a quick look at SEO
plug-in from here you can add SEO
title from here you can edit the slug
slug is the part of URL you can add the
necessary keyword here in the meta
description section you can add the meta
description which Al together looks like
this where this part is your slug the
keyword you want to add in your page
should be added in the focus keyphrase
section the SEO analysis section shows
the SEO improvements in your
content now moving towards the
readability
analysis readability analysis shows
Improvement in the textual content of
the page if both the indicators are
green then your SEO and readability both
are good to go for us SEO we have
covered the significant features and now
we will understand one of the essential
SEO tools Google
analytics website tracking plays an
important control in SEO it helps in
understanding the user behavior on your
website Google analytics is an Analytics
tool used for tracking a
website the standard version of Google
analytics is free we can integrate
Google analytics with Google
ads the main features of Google
analytics include tracking session
duration of users pages per session and
tracking website traffic and bounce rate
of
users let's take a quick tour of Google
analytics here you can see reports of
users for last 7
days now go to the report section in the
the
dashboard you can reset the time span to
get the desired data from
here go to
retention where you can see the number
of new users and the number of returning
users to your
website
to know the data on
monetization go to the monetization
section here you can see the
monetization data for the selected time
span we will understand Google analytics
features and how it works in the
upcoming videos in detail moving ahead
with the next tool which is small SU
tools pism
Checker duplicate content is hated by
search engines if not taken seriously
this could hurt your search rankings the
plagarism Checker detects duplicate data
in your content and shows its
source you need to open this plagarism
Checker here you can add your content
manually
after adding your content manually you
just need to undergo a
verification and click on check
plagarism
and here we get the results the content
is 100% unique in case if we get any
duplicate content we can check the
sources from
here as our content is unique we are not
getting any results
here in case if you don't want to enter
your content manually you can upload the
document file from
here note that this Checker checks for
the top thousand words of your content
so in case of lendy content you can
break the content and then check for its
uniqueness in case you don't want to
purchase the pro version moreover you
can also add a page URL to check the
uniqueness of the content the page has
over here and follow the same process by
clicking on the check plagarism
button the plagarism Checker by grammar
is also one of the free tools used for
checking uniqueness in the content the
next tool that we have in our bucket is
the paid speed
insights for the data provided by go
Google the bounce rate increases to
32% as the page load speed increases
from 1 to 3 seconds page speed speed
insights is the page speed check tool
page speed insights is used to test the
speed of a web page and it is a free
service offered by Google developers
results of paid speed insights show what
real users are experiencing about your
page on mobile devices and desktops to
understand how to use it let's go to PID
speed insights and select the URL of the
website for which you want to undergo
for the check enter the URL and click on
analyze
button now choose whether you wish to
undergo a check for mobile or desktop
device here I'll select a desktop
device
just in few seconds you will get the
required
results another tool that we can use is
tools. pingdom dcom
which has free as well as paid versions
moving forward to the next magic tool
which is sem
rush to grow your business it is
essential to keep an eye on what your
competitors are doing this will help you
to understand their strengths and
Implement similar strategies for your
business as well for this you need to
carry out competitor analysis sem Rush
is the competitor analysis tool that
gives a complete work through the
competitors's data like keywords
backlinks top performing content
campaigns
Etc it has free as well as paid versions
you can access free trials by simply
signing up on semrush.com
so let's take a quick overview of how it
works
log to your sem rash
account
here enter the URL of your
competitor here you can choose a
geographical location for which the
analysis is to be
perform by adding URL you get all the
competitor data here I have added sem
Rush as a competitor so we are getting
so many details of sem Rush The Organic
keywords the organic traffic paid
keywords paid traffic referral domains
and Authority
score we can add a competitor as well
from
here now here you can see the data of
both sem rush and
RFS other than SCM rush you can use
spu which has some free daily trials now
let me tell you about an excellent
auditing
tool which is screaming
frog dear Learners it is essential to
know how your website is performing and
for this you need to carry out frequent
website
audits screaming frog is a website
auditing tool that works similar to web
crawlers it has free as well as paid
versions some features of free version
include finding broken links errors and
redirects analyzing page title and
metadata href Lang attributes auditing
finding duplicate content Etc with a
craw limit of 500
URLs let's know more about it go to
screaming
frog now from here download the tool on
your
system check various resources
provided on how to learn the tool from
here
another alternative tool you can use for
auditing is
suity where you can enter the URL and
get the audit reports moving further
with another free tool which is rf's
backlink
Checker gaining high quality backlinks
is an essential factor for SEO ranking
as it shows the trust of other websites
in your content moreover it helps in
building building the authority of your
website with the help of backlink
Checker you get the data of all the
websites linking to your website rf's
backlink Checker shows the data of top
100 backlinks top five anchors and top
five pages including total number of
backlinks and referring domains in its
free version let's have a quick look at
the
tool
here let's take example of wikipedia.com
so here we are checking backlinks for
wikipedia.com
now click on check back
link
here we got details of backlinks for
wikipedia.com
alternatives to rf's backlink Checker
are SC Rush backlink Analytics tool and
Su ability by signing up with these
tools you will get some free trials for
your site last but not the least let's
know about the mobile SEO tool which is
mobile friendly test studies show that
in year 2020 60% of traffic was through
mobile devices thus it is essential to
keep your website mobile friendly as
well here is when the mobile friendly
test comes into
action it helps to check if your website
is mobile friendly or not go to mobile
friendly
test and enter the URL of your
website suppose I enter here
www.wikipedia.com
now click on test
URL
here you get the
results we can see that the page is
mobile
friendly to check more details you can
navigate to your search console
account well if you think we are done
for today then then then keep watching
this video as we have two bonus tools
for
you so here comes the first
one the
serator search results vary with mobile
devices also your brand ranking May
differ from country to Country to get
reports on this serator will be your
alltime companion it shows how search
results May differ for mobile devices or
locations let's see how it
works go to
serator now let's fill in the required
fields
now let's select the
location let's run the live test
and here we get the
results that's it daily you can run
three free live test isn't this
amazing
without taking a minute let's know about
the second bonus
tool which
is the rich results
test you must have seen these kinds of
search results on search
Pages let's dive deep into
it
yes these type of results are known as
Rich
results to check whether your site is
optimized for Rich results go to Rich
results test and add the URL of your
website let's add the URL of Simply
learn
now click on test
URL complete the
verification and check the
report so here we can see that simply
learns website is eligible for Google
searches Rich
results to monitor Rich results for your
complete website you can easily navigate
to your search console
account during our childhood we have
heard the fictional stories of robots
taking over various household courses
making the lives of humans easy peasy
but if you're not aware then these
fictional stories are turning into
reality though not in the form of
physical robots but yes in the form of
computer programs and apps with the help
of artificial intelligence and machine
learning Technologies confused let me
introduce to you to chat GPD a
pre-trained model that interacts with
user in a conversational way chat GPT is
founded by open Ai and the model is
based on supervised and reinforcement
learning so are you excited to know more
about chat GPT chat GPT has various
application in various domains in this
video we are going to see the
application of chat GPT in the SEO
domain also we are going to discuss how
chat GPT will play an important role in
search engine optimization so here is a
question for you chat GPT is based on
which of the following GPT model created
by open AI option one chat GPT 1 option
two chat gpt2 option three chat gpt3 and
option four none of the above let us
know your answer in the comment section
below and if your answer is correct you
will get a hard from Simply learn we
know that SEO rankings depends on
various factors like on page
optimization off page optimization and
more while using chat GPT we will
understand how how chat GPT helps in
various Su ranking parameters and
reduces the manual work so without any
further delay let's begin so to begin
with let's open chat
GPT we need to go to new chat which is
already open
here let's start by we will try to
demonstrate an SE optimized uh blog in
this demonstration so let's get some
keyword ideas for the blog so before
that let's choose what kind of blog we
want to create I really love traveling
so let's try to create a travel blog so
for the travel blog we'll find some good
keywords
so here you can see we are getting some
suggestions for the travel destinations
we can choose any of
them
okay so here we got around uh seven of
the
results so let's try to get something
for
Japan
so just me good keywords to create a
blog on
Japan okay so what I understand from
this is we are just just getting few of
the random
keywords okay so it
is it is showing that these keywords
cover a range of topics related to
Japanese culture history food and
more uh out of these I guess we can
start with the places here are few
places like Mount Fiji
Tokyo and everything so let's try to
create a
blog on top 10 places to visit in
Japan okay so we are getting places to
visit in
Japan
let's try to get keywords related to top
10 places in
Japan
okay so we are getting some of the
keyword
recommendations and it is also
suggesting that by using these keywords
our content will be more dis
discoverable and it will be easy for
rank for for for SE for search rankings
write me a Blog on top
10 places to
visit in
Japan so the idea is we will try to
write a blog and after which we will try
to uh uh optimize the blog with respect
to the keyword top 10 places to visit in
Japan and we will also uh see whether
all the SEO practices can be easily
applicable or not using chat
GPT so here you can see we are getting a
Blog with the introduction with top 10
places and probably what I expect is to
get a good conclusion out of
it also like uh uh chat jpt provides you
the facility so that you can reduce the
length of your content the textual
content the blog or article or anything
you want uh to several number of words
like if this Blog has 2,000 or 5,000
words you can just ask chat GPD to
reduce it to 2,000 or th000 words
also
so here you can see that before when we
searched there were only one liners
about these destinations these places in
Japan and now we are getting a detail
about all the 10
places
definitely we have targeted this blog
for the uh keyword top 10 places to
visit in Japan however we can ask for
some more keywords to to increase its
reach suggest few more
relevant keywords for my block
okay so we are getting some more
keywords
here for any blog it is really important
to have a very good title so we will try
to implement a c achy title for this
blog as a good title helps the user to
click on your content and it uh
increases the possibility to get more
and more
traffic so here you can see the title is
completely keyword optimize our keyword
is top 10 places to visit in Japan and
here I can see most of the suggestions
most of the suggested titles have the
keyword top 10 places or top 10
destinations which is somewhat similar
to what we are
expecting at the best
suitable title
in my
blog okay so we are getting something
different here The Ultimate Guide to
Japan's hidden gems 10 places you can't
miss okay so here we got title for a
Blog but here we can see there is a
slight limitation that it is suggesting
the title but it is not adding it to our
blog and representing it again to us
optimize my
blog for the
keyword top
10 places to visit in Japan top 10
places to visit in
Japan with an
optimized
title
okay so we have to do it manually it's
not able to add the title in the
blog
optimize log
for
the
keyword top 10 places to visit
and okay so here it is showing the
relevant
suggestions
so maybe there is a
slight ambiguity in the query that's why
it's not representing us the correct
results we are going to optimize our
blog using all these
factors
visit in
Japan
again these are the
suggestions
let's try to implement these one by
one add headings H1
H2 in the above
blog so yes we are getting the updated
versions having H1 and H2
and yes you can see easily that the
title of the blog is in H1 and the rest
are maybe in
H2 H1 and H2 tags are some of the
practices in the on page optimization
which uh helps the search engine boards
to understand that this is something
important really important uh for the
page and they pick up these hints for uh
getting your uh page
rank so yes it is
implemented
okay so our blog is completed with H1
and H2
implementations let's try to get some
interlinks for this blog interlinks have
their own importance as interlinking
your blog with other pages of your
website or your blogging Pages this will
help you to gain the traffic from other
pages to your blog and uh uh putting the
traffic from your blog to other pages of
your
website also it helps the search engine
boards to understand the crawl structure
understand the website structure
also
so suggest me
few ENT links for the above
blog so yes definitely these are the
relevant and uh expected links we are
getting so if you have any of these uh
blog pages in your uh website or if you
have created any of these blogs earlier
do Interlink
it
which of the
above can I use in my blog so definitely
there are number of suggestions but if
if you want to choose one how can you
pick the one let's see if we get the
relevant thing for
this
okay so it is not only suggesting that
we can use all of the above but it is
also showing the significance of
interlinking okay moving
ahead
so till now we have optimized our blog
for keyword top 10 places we have tried
to get some of the keywords relevant to
the uh top 10 places to visit in Japan
we have added headings and we have tried
to get some of the good Interlink
suggestions to add interlinks in our
blogs which are some of the good
practices of the on page optimizations
so next moving ahead head in another on
page optimization technique is let's try
to get a cover image for this
blog so by by getting a cover image
suggestions we will try to implement the
image optimization technique for our
blog
page
okay so it is showing uh some of the
suggestions related to the diversity of
the country panormic view of Tokyo
Skyline the beautiful image of Koto
traditional Temple Mount Fuji
hiroshima's peace Memorial
Park so so we will try to pick one and
uh see if we are getting any image
idea let's take for Mount
Fuji suggest me the image idea for
Mount so let's see we we have seen in
generic for all now let's see for this
uh image suggestion specific to M
Fuji okay definitely it is showing a
number of suggestions for the specific
Mount Fuji
image so if you are looking to create
another block for Mount Fuji then these
ideas are easy to take
up
optimize the
mount Fugi image for my
block here are some tips to optimize the
image for Mount Fuji for my blog which
are they're showing that the image
should be high
resolution then a clear
subject definitely if you have a large
image a large file size it really gets
difficult to load and the page load
speed will increase so if you have a
large file size the image should be
compressed without reducing its quality
image
quality we should have descriptive file
names and all
tags
okay so let's try to get a very good
file name and all tag also we'll try to
implement a good caption because adding
a caption is very good in the uh when
considered as a
user
so get me
good
image title
and ALT tag
for Mount fug
image so there is importance for Al tag
as search engines are Bots uh they won't
able to identify the image directly so
alxs helps the search engines to
understand what the image is
about
so yes it is showing not one but number
of suggestions for all the Mount Fuji
recommendations which we got
earlier so we will try to choose one and
get a caption for
it write a
good
caption
for for the
image
Scenic
Fugi Five Lakes
Region
so yes definitely we're getting
suggestions
here I guess this caption is quite long
so let's try to reduce it to 40
words reduce the
above caption
to not even 40 let's do it in 20 20
words okay this one is
better now let's try to get the image if
there is
any
choose the
mount Fugi image for my
blog choose image it should not I
repeat choose the perfect
illustration
for Mount
Fugi image for my
block so you can see here that it is not
choosing any image but it is again
providing us the suggestion what we can
choose again this is the limitation that
it is not showing us any of the image we
will try to put it in another way to get
an
image if it really works we can get
it okay so it is not possible to
download or get an image presentation
using chat
GPT we can only get the recommendations
to choose the image and yes it is
showing some suggestions of un unsplash
pixels or Shuttle stock to download the
image so we can uh really navigate to
these websites and download some of the
required image for our blog so we we
have uh completed here with the image
optimizations let's try to get some
video ideas because again having a video
is uh catchy factor for the users
visiting your
website or your blog
page suggest me suggest video ideas
for the
above
blog
okay so if we are getting few of the
video
ideas
which of the above idea is best match
for my blog let's try to extract anyone
from the
above
okay so it is completely dependent on
the user's Choice what a user wants so
here I'll
choose
for again we will continue with Mount
Fuji
only
provide video
optimization
ideas video
optimizations
for Mount Fuji with
for above
blog okay so it is showing us some of
the suggestions which uh which we can
Implement for a video as we do not have
any video here we can just take these
recommendations and optimize whatever
the video of our
choice so let's take the thumbnail
suggestions in our next query uh if it
can suggest us a Mount Fuji uh thumbnail
uh image suggestion uh and the video tag
suggestion
right suggest
me
good thumbnail
idea for Mount
Fuji
video thumbnails have the Major Impact
for any videos it is the only thing
uh I
repeat
thumbnails thumbnails are one of the
important factors which encourages the
user to click on your video and watch
the complete
video so definitely having a good
thumbnail will help your content to
rank so yes we have got around 10 of the
thumbnail ideas from which we can
Implement any one uh as of the video we
are having for our
blog so we are done with the thumbnail
ideas after which we will get
we will try to get video tags so for
getting video tags let's get for all of
them find
me
video tags
for the all of
above
thumbnail
suggestions
tags are important to help the user to
get your videos in the search
list like if someone uh uh types Mount
Fuji in the search box and if the Mount
Fuji keyword is or a tag is added to
your video tag it is more likely to get
searched and appear in the search result
and possibly us a May click on
it so here we have tried to get uh try
to implement some of the good uh some of
the important um on page optimization in
practices now let's try to get backlinks
which is one of the most famous off page
optimization
technique above
block
okay so it is
showing some of the link
suggestions so basically backlinks are
the
links which points from another website
or another web page to your web page or
your website so getting backlink uh is
one of the trust factors in the search
engine eyes that your content is really
unique and more of more users wants to
read it and share it with another uh
users so the search engines by by by
these search engines understand that
your content is really good and it is
worth of ranking so definitely getting a
good backlink from a very good authority
websites is uh fruitful for your
content so let's try to get
which
pages on web are
suitable to get backlinks for my
blog so here we are getting some of the
ideas or suggestions that which Pages we
can choose to get a backlink so here is
industry specific websites so if you are
writing a travel blog there should be a
travel trip ad uh Trip Advisor like
websites uh which are showing more of
the trip oriented or bookings related
oriented for travel or uh
destinations there are few of the
directories okay government websites
which are the tourism websites in our
case right
now blogging websites and social media
platforms which can be relevant to the
current scenario which we are using here
so let's check how can we get back
links from
the
above
recommendations for my
blog okay guest
posting
broken link
building okay these are some of the
backlink building methods which we are
getting so that we can find one and get
one of the uh I
repeat so these are some of the backlink
building strategies which we are getting
in the recommendation so we can
Implement any of these to get a backing
for our
block
let's choose the specific platform and
try to get the
recommendations or the ideas to get back
links for the from the blogging
site
so we can Implement these ideas and it
it may be possible to get
backlinks
now that we have got some of the ideas
to get backlinks for our blog let's try
to add the catchy meta data for our blog
metad data like having meta title or
meta description these are the only uh
data which is um which is appearing in
the search results as you you have seen
that in the search result the link the
Blue Link we get is the meta title of
our blog page or a website page or any
page on the web whereas a few lines
written below that link is the meta
description that we are providing to let
the user know that what the blog is
exactly about so it is considered to be
a good practice to have the targeted
keyword in the title as well as in the
description so let's try to get
one
s
the create
SEO
optimize meta title and
meta description for my
blog
so we are getting some suggestions
here top 10 places to visit in Japan
discover the best place to visit in
Japan top 10 destinations definitely we
have here top 10
destinations see also we are getting
some of the notes
that it is good to have meta title less
than 60 characters
so if if it is more than 60 character
you may get the dot dot part and the
title will not be clearly visible in the
search result
page so let's try to again optimize The
Meta title and meta description for top
10 places to visit in
Japan
description for the key
word top
10 places
to visit in
Japan okay
so we can use any of the one the one we
have got the recommendation the
previously and this one also both are
completely relevant to our
content so one of the technical SE
factor which we are going to see here is
getting the URL
recommendation uh URLs are the important
factor uh it helps the search engine
boards to understand understand about
the page as the URL is the first thing
search engines may be visiting to come
to your
page so uh it is a good practice to have
the keyword in your url rather than
having some of the abrupt characters
like x a r at rate these kind of stuffs
in the link so let's
create the URL
suggestions suggest me
SEO
optimized URL for the above
blog see so here we are getting top 10
places to visit in Japan which is
definitely our blog and as a keyword we
are using it to optimize our content
and it is placed in the URL so this URL
is completely
correct also these kind of suggestions
are very good for the newbies in the uh
search engine domain as they will
definitely understand why and what we
are doing to optimize our
pages so next moving ahead with some of
the non-technical aspects which may
impact which may definitely impact to
bring the traffic so let's try to get
some of the sharing suggestions
like which
platforms should
I I
repeat which sharing
options should I add add in
my
block so out of the mentioned uh sharing
buttons we can add any of them adding at
least three to four sharing buttons is
considered to be really good out of
which there are many common like
Facebook is really common common then
Reddit is really very common WhatsApp
Shares are really common Twitter Shares
are really common so you can choose any
of these to add it in your
blogs does
commenting
on my blog
impact
on traffic source so here we are taking
the suggestion that that will this help
or
not again this is again linked to the
back links that if we are adding the
comment section someone else may ask for
a backlink for their web and this is
again uh going in symbiotic way like if
they are asking for a backlink for from
your blog you can even ask from
them so this is the way of or part of a
communication to get a back links as
well can you find
the
duplicate
content in above log so duplicate
content is a concept where search
engines you you must be aware that
search engines are really in love with
the unique content so having a duplicate
content may
really uh affect your uh uh web
visibility and it is possible that your
page may get dead after a
time so plagarism is not at all allowed
uh when you're creating a Content it is
not suggested in any
case Okay so it is not uh able to uh
charity is not able to identify the
duplicate content however uh it is
suggesting us some of the tools like
copy scape or sideliner to understand
if the content we are creating for our
blog is duplicate or
not and let's get some suggestions how
to
make content
unique just in case if someone is not
aware to create a unique
content we can get some of the tips
here
okay so we have got some of the
suggestions Also let's try to uh see one
of the other aspects of technical SE
that is 4 not4 pages 4 not4 pages
are really not are not likely to get
searched
because I
repeat let's try to see another aspect
of technical
Su uh try to find some 44 pages on the
website
so from this I can understand that
though we have not posted any blog link
or any uh internal links that leads to
to that blog which we are expecting this
is not the clear idea we are providing
but yes uh to find 404
Pages uh it is not possible for the chat
GPT to get one but we can use uh some of
the tools suggested like uh screaming
frog or Google search console where we
get the detailed report of the broken
links or 44 pages that is the dead pages
of our
website so let's wrap up from the uh
view of the technical SEO perspective
let's consider one of the scenario that
we have published this blog and how can
we promote this blog to reach more of
the relevant audience
so
okay so we are getting some of the
recommendations that we can share our
blog on social media reach to the
influencer uh add it as a guest
post and Link back to this this blog
email marketing yes it is the most
trending technique to reach more of the
audiences p advertising
commenting content
syndication yes medium and Linkin are
the very famous platforms for this
online
communities so you can you can
definitely uh try to be the member of
the online communities and forums where
you can just put up the link and the
members of your Niche may definitely
visit your content and share it with
others
also so yes we we have seen that uh
search for as as a perspective of search
engine optimization chat GPT is uh
helpful really really helpful to create
the in content Creation in optimizations
and many of the other things so if you
are looking to become an Su professional
then look no further than simply learns
postgraduate program in digital
marketing find the cost Link in
description box for more information at
GPT and Google B are the two AI chatbots
you must have heard about they bought an
immense change in the way we operate now
from web development to digital
marketing from cloud computing to cyber
security they are now everywhere you
just name it and they have it trust me
the use of these chat Bots has changed
everything now if you want to create a
complete YouTube video just ask them and
rest ass show they'll take care for your
task not just that but if you want to
create a search engine optimized content
whether it be for your website or on
YouTube these AI tools can help you with
search content search engine
optimization is not easy it takes a lot
to optimize your content so that people
can get to see it on top but are these
AI tools thread to people engaged in
search engine optimization in this video
we'll not discuss what these AI tools
can do for you but we'll discuss if AI
tools like chat GPT or Google bot will
take over SEO or not but before that
that if you enjoy watching these videos
and find them interesting please
subscribe to our Channel because we
bring the best videos for you daily hit
the Bell icon to get notified whenever
we drop a new vision optimization the
goal of SEO is to make a website more
visible and bring in income from natural
traffic it entails crafting excellent
content for a specific audience and
optimizing a website for search engines
online marketers employ AI to accomplish
various tasks such as keyword research
content optimization and Link building
more quickly businesses can boost their
ranks and increase their revenue by
using AI in SEO strategies additionally
by automating routine processes it can
save time and resources also if you want
to master the field of search engine
optimization and digital marketing
simply learns postgraduate program in
digital marketing is clearly the right
choice for you this postgraduate program
in collaboration with perdu will help
you master search engine optimization
content marketing web web analytics
keyword management and research website
management and optimization URL
management search psychology keyword
research Advanced ad features and more
not only these skills but you will also
learn a number of tools like SE ranking
hoot suit Google ads Keyword Planner and
much more so hurry up and find the
course Link in the description box for
more details hear it from our Learners
who have experienced massive success in
digital marketing through this course
I'm MO to the United States 4 years ago
to live with my family I have a
background in social media but doing the
same was difficult here more so because
my English is not that good last year I
decided to pursue the professional
certification program in digital
marketing from puru University offered
by simple learn I like that the course
provides such a flexible schedule for
attending the live classes it came with
a record fature with a blessing for
working professionals like me helped me
make significant progress and I already
using the skills to sell my products
online I believe that I have come one
step closer to living my dream life in
America so let's talk about SEO
developments with chat GPT and Google
bar undoubtedly the influence AI is
anticipated to have on search engines
have been highlighted by the recent
launches of Google's B and chat GPT
assisted B although these recent
advancements pose a severe danger they
also present opportunities for digital
marketers to seize in the world full of
seu things change all the time and stops
are never stti the page that a search
engine displays as a result of a user
search query is known as the search
engine result page or SE this is why
it's important to be able to change with
the times and benefit from new
technological developments digital
marketers increasingly use AI for
keyword research heading ideas and
content optimizations this is so they
can concentrate on the jobs that need
human interaction small sites May
produce original SEO friendly material
much more quickly with chat GP than they
could without it for instance however
it's vital to remember that this is only
a portion of the process it can assist
you with creating and providing meta
descriptions and titles keyword research
heading recommendations for pages and
posts article ideation and composing
copy so let's talk about the role of AI
in keyword research every business
utilizes AI to increase productivity
automate labor intensive operations and
make data driven choices numerous
Industries including finance and banking
e-commerce retail media gaming research
space exploration Transportation
automative medicine manufacturing
security and more uses it in various
ways the Google AdWords Keyword Planner
and the Google Trends tool are two of
the most widely used free artificial
intelligence keyword research tools you
may find keywords with a lot of search
volume and little competition using
these tools another crucial aspect to
take into account when choosing keywords
for your website is intent this is so
because users frequently have a purpose
while searching for goods and services
although it might be challenging to
ensure your website appears high on
search engine visual Pages especially
with Google's algorithm adjustments SEO
companies and marketers must constantly
check their websites to make sure that
their websites are not falling in the
servers they can use AI to automatically
analyze search traffic statistics and
website content to spot potential issues
before their arise they can then address
these problems and offer consistent
organic rankings this is a game changer
for SEO companies and marketers who
realize on manual SEO efforts to get
traffic to their websites but the main
question is will chat GPT or Google bar
take over SE the answer is clearly a big
no why chat Bots like chat GPT and Bot
cannot replace seu they can help
generate content for your website or
video but SEO involves more than just
content creation it includes tasks like
keyword research link building and
Technical seu where you'll need an SEO
expert because chatbots can't decide how
to build links and which links will get
you more organic traffic SEO is
constantly changing due to search engine
algorithms search engines like Google
and Bing regularly update their
algorithms making SEO a dynamic field
SEO requires human judgment and decision
making the end of discussion because
determining which keywords to Target and
which links to build require expertise
and human decision making a chatbot
can't do it in fact the real power of
search engine optimizations lies not in
their mechanical abilities but in their
creativity and ability to understand
what people are searching for and why
that's something that AI Technologies
may never be able to to replicate and
it's what makes human SEO experts such a
valuable asset so while it's true that
AI Technologies may eventually be able
to take over some of the aspects of seu
there are still plenty of rooms for
human experts to thrive whether you are
a seasoned SE your professional or just
starting out there's still a place for
you in this exciting and ever evolving
field let's keep an eye on the
developments in AI technology and see
how it can augment and enhance our
skills rather than replace ing them
entirely who knows with the power of AI
and human expertise combined the future
of SEO may be even brighter than we can
imagine so with that we have come to the
end of this discussion although everyone
can have different opinions on this but
I hope you guys must have got an idea
about why these AI tools are not a
threat to a if you still have any
questions or doubts let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
experts will help you at the earliest so
here we wrap up the SEO crash calls if
if you are looking to master SEO have
look at digital marketing Masters
program by simply learn apply discount
code
ytb5 to get easy discount on your
purchase find the cost Link in the
description box if you like this video
hit the like button consider subscribing
to our Channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from us till then
keep watching keep learning staying
ahead in your career requires continuing
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in Cutting
Edge domains including data science
cloud computing cyber security AI
machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here